It's actually not live.
Because you know how on YouTube it's not instant?
Like the live thing is an instant.
So like okay now we're live.
I think.
Hey guys.
Wait I don't know yet.
My chat hasn't responded.
There's panning.
Do not mode.
RPR is gone.
Yeah time to wait.
RPR is late.
This is not great.
Yeah he's still waking up guys.
Oh wait.
My chat's not showing up on stream.
Oh yeah okay.
All right.
We're actually live guys.
So we're waiting for RPR right now.
So it's just me and Rustia.
We were telling secrets.
Yeah we're telling secrets.
Yeah.
Oh no.
We're gonna give you FOMO.
I'm gonna backstab Doki Bird now.
No!
I'm gonna backstab you.
Yes I do.
Yes.
I do.
It's...
Really?
You got secrets for me?
Yes I do.
If I can't say it.
You should tell me after the stream.
What do you mean?
You literally...
We were talking about the beginning of the stream.
Where we're like whoa.
Whoa.
No that's...
That's actually not a secret you know.
That's not a secret?
Yeah.
We're talking like...
We're like...
Okay then say it.
I'm chatting about the aegis.
And then we're saying like...
Um...
Why is like aegis like um for like for chat next year is gonna be like in Sapporo right?
Like why Sapporo in like for championship?
Yeah.
Like should be Tokyo or like Osaka.
Because they're poor chat.
I didn't say that.
I didn't say that guys.
I love Apex.
I love aegis respawn.
You guys were great to me.
But anyway.
What Restia said was that he was saying that...
That Tokyo was too expensive.
Obviously I didn't believe him.
Yeah.
I think Sapporo is a great place for Aelgs to champion that.
Sapporo is a great place.
Yeah.
But it's...
No it's true.
Everybody knows.
Yeah.
It's gonna be beautiful.
It's gonna...
It's gonna be a lot of snow.
And they probably don't know like how heavy like snow is.
I hope like the players coming in will like be ready for the snow.
Because I've been in Sapporo too.
It's known for like the winter.
I mean it's pretty.
It's just really fucking cold compared to other places.
Actually went to like Hokkaido in like five months ago.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
How was Hokkaido?
Yeah.
It was like...
It was fun.
It was like really huge.
I gotta say like the food is really good.
Yeah.
But like the point is I went out with like my family.
So it's like my mom and dad.
And then like...
They're pretty old.
So like they have like a...
Like I had a tour trip like for you know boomers for old man.
And then like the whole thing we did was eat.
We go on a bus.
We go to like a spot for 20 minutes.
And then we eat.
And we go on a bus and we go to the spot.
It's just the whole day of eating.
Yeah.
I mean that's great.
That's my ultimate vacation right there.
Just go eat and no tourist destination.
Somebody was like it's just two degrees.
Guys.
Yes.
But like they're going in February.
So it's gonna get cold.
It might be two degrees right now.
But they're going in February guys.
Not like they're going right now to Sapporo.
Yeah.
Did you see like the ice sculpture?
Oh wait.
Would there be ice sculpture?
No that's during the summer.
Right?
Yeah.
So like I also went to like Sapporo.
So it's like there's like even a little snow like left.
Yeah.
You know.
Even though it's just starting.
Right?
The snow is just starting and stuff.
No.
It's like just ending.
But like for like in winter.
Oh my god.
I think the org has no idea how it's gonna be.
Yeah.
So like the support guys in Japan is like oh my god February for championship.
I was gonna say why not more in the spring or like the summer.
I guess because like it's champions.
They can't really delay.
Champions always been in like you know in either January or February.
So like they can't really change the dates for the champions land.
So it just had to be that that day.
Wait you're gonna be there.
You have to cast.
Yeah.
Probably gonna be there.
Like probably not after today.
Yeah.
Probably not now after what he said today.
Guys remember to clip this and say.
No I already said.
Yeah what did he say?
You know it made me for like watch parties.
So they have like on-site watch parties.
Yeah yeah yeah.
They invite like different people.
Like they invite like nice wig.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I like more probably the Brazilian streamers or stuff.
Yeah yeah.
I'm not getting paid dude.
I'm not getting paid chat.
Yeah but you get.
He gets a free hotel and travel.
Travel to Sapporo.
He gets free travel.
He's doing it for exposure.
He's doing.
Yeah yeah yeah.
That's the point.
That's what they actually told me.
For the exposure guys.
You know all I'm saying is that you know.
I would.
You guys don't even need to give me a hotel or flight.
I can play for my own hotel and flight.
But I'll do the official casting for them.
I.
Hahaha.
You could guys.
ALGS.
You can save.
Even more money.
If you hire me.
To take over Restia's spot.
I won't even.
I won't be able to speak it.
Speak Chinese.
But that's okay.
You can't speak Cantonese.
Even then I can't even know the Apex terms in Cantonese.
What do you mean Restia?
I don't even know what Apex Legends.
How to say Apex Legends in Cantonese.
Like what do you mean?
But I'll still do it for free.
By the way.
I'll still.
If you guys.
If you any.
If they want to save money.
I'll still do it for free.
See I'm a team player.
I'm a team player.
Right here.
I don't know.
Where the fuck is RPR?
How is he like.
Okay.
Like.
I guess like because.
I don't know.
I don't know if he's gonna be like face camming or whatever.
He said maybe he has to look presentable.
I have like a collab of 15 minutes ago.
It's gonna be fine.
They can wait.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Have you been playing rank Restia?
What's your rank?
Glatchem.
Not really high.
So I think it's fine.
Okay.
That's cool.
I'm bronze.
It's fine.
I definitely haven't been playing rank.
I was playing.
I was playing duos earlier like just pubs and I fucking hate E-district so much.
It's like I swear one.
It's the worst map that's ever made.
I don't know if you like E-district but I hate E-district so much.
I actually.
I actually like the map.
You know.
Really?
You like it?
Like what do you like about it?
I think it's like there's a lot of like cover.
You know like you can go close on enemies.
Of course like this third party is like really like there's a lot of third parties.
But yeah.
Yeah.
I like in like in close fights and I guess like it for rank it might be better because like if you're camping or whatever in rank but like pubs is so frustrating on E-district.
It's just it is so frustrating but I just didn't like the area where like there's like a specific area in that map where there's no loot.
Like I don't understand like it's just hide and seek like literally you could play hide and seek on that one section.
I still don't know what section it is.
Yeah.
Like because I landed there.
The funny part about E-district is like.
Oh probably like two weeks ago I actually like hosted a tournament and like.
Yeah.
Invited like all like the Taiwanese like big streamers and youtubers.
I made them and then it was supposed to be Olympus and World's Edge.
But like they made like a new map.
So Olympus was gone and then it was E-district.
I was not even in custom lobbies.
Actually like pick Olympus and custom lobbies.
What the fuck.
All right guys we're playing E-district.
Yeah.
Everybody was like no.
Like they're like.
But we practiced the other maps.
They actually didn't practice the other map.
But like.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Yeah.
But I was like anyway I'm not playing so you guys are playing.
You're just like yay I get to just watch.
I mean that's good.
That's good.
At least you don't have to.
I'm just happy rank map isn't E-district.
I don't really like.
I know like maybe it's better for rank but I just.
E-district makes me so mad.
Yeah.
Because people.
People play so scummy in E-district.
People are like calling E-district like the basement.
The ba- Like we play two maps of War's Edge and everybody's like oh it's fun.
And then we're going to E-district.
No they're just like okay I'm going.
I'm gonna uninstall Apex now.
Oh my god.
So I'm happy.
I took my.
I took my chances.
All right.
Let's play one.
We could just play Knockout Rumble while we wait.
I guess.
For RPR.
Yeah nice RPR.
I wouldn't have to hear me now.
Yo bro are you out?
Like did he go back to sleep?
Like what happened?
Where is he?
Okay it's.
I'm gonna see if he's off.
No he's.
It says do not disturb.
So he's technically online.
Don't worry.
He'll.
He'll be back guys.
He'll be here guys.
All right.
Also by the way I know we didn't introduce Restia.
But if you guys don't know Restia.
He's a cat girl.
Or he's an actual cat.
He's an actual.
Yeah he used to be a cat girl.
Now he's just an actual cat.
Hey RPR.
Oh is he here?
How's your sleep?
Hey we're talking about how you're late.
You guys want to know what they said about you?
Time to wait.
RPR is late.
Wait.
The funny part is like.
RPR is mauled.
I don't care.
This is the first time I'm late.
And I'm allowed to be late.
It's 8 a.m.
What do you mean this is your first time being late?
That is not true.
This is not your first time being late.
You've been late before.
I know you've been late before.
I've never been late before.
Yes you have.
I have not.
Yeah you have.
Okay when?
I just know you.
Okay chat.
When has he ever been late?
No because like you've been late so many times.
I don't keep track anymore.
Oh like what?
That one time when we played the Helldivers.
That was my fault.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yes you were late then.
Yeah.
No I wasn't dumbass.
That was Axel.
That was not Axel.
That was.
Whoever the fuck.
Someone was late.
Oh what about one time we played.
What about that one time we played.
We played lethal company and I was waiting 20 minutes on you fuckers.
Okay.
What about chained together when I was on time and no one else was.
What about that one?
Okay.
I'm allowed to be.
No you were late then.
I remember.
I was not late.
Yes you were.
You were so late.
Anyway I'm in the fucking sub machine.
Oh my god why am I lagging.
I don't know.
No.
This is fine.
This is called karma.
No it's not.
Hey GG.
How have you been doing?
No it's not.
I'm terrible.
I have to wake up at 8am to play.
I'm okay now.
Yeah true.
What do you mean?
It's practice for BLGS.
Yeah.
Yeah you got to be up early for BLGS too.
It's okay guys I'm not.
What do you mean early?
BLGS is played at like fucking 8pm JST or something.
Yeah.
Yeah that's so.
Yeah it's just it's almost like 8am and you just swapped the two.
It's almost the same.
I actually asked like Doki if she can play at like 8am.
No he asked me if I could play at 4am in the morning and I was like no.
This was.
Oh no.
I got 2v1.
What the fuck.
Why do you mean why not?
If she gets to play at 4am in the morning then I'm fucking 8am in the morning.
No it's not.
It is not easier.
This is like.
You're awake anyway at 4am in the morning.
I am not.
What are you doing at 4am.
I go to bed.
I have so much stuff to do.
I go to bed early.
As in like.
Why do you lie?
What do you mean?
I am not awake at 4am.
When do you go to bed?
I go to bed at 1am.
Or earlier.
No you don't.
Yes I do.
Yes I do like.
I told.
I definitely do.
Yes I do.
I do.
Yeah all women do is lie bro.
Whoa.
I don't know what happened to you but I never lie.
No you don't.
Okay I am taking the zone by the way.
Yeah.
No.
JP are you.
Oh my god.
You definitely never lie.
I would never.
That's.
Fuck.
Are you.
Hey what rank are you guys?
Huh?
What did you say?
What rank are you guys?
I am bronze.
How the fuck are you bronze?
Because I don't play rank.
What do you mean how the fuck am I.
Okay I am a restiest plat.
What about you?
I am diamond.
What the fuck are you doing?
I am so weak.
Okay.
Fucking my dude.
What are you doing?
No you are not going to fucking turn this shit on me.
No no.
What are you doing?
Why are you diamond?
The season just started.
Because I was playing ranked with my teammates.
What do you want from me?
Don't fucking blame me because you are fucking slacking off.
What do you mean slacking off?
I have other priorities right now.
I can't just play rank all the time.
I am a variety streamer.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Yeah variety.
I am a variety bullshitter.
I am a variety streamer.
Today I played Freddy Fish and the case of the missing kelp seed.
Oh you fucking nerd.
I am going to get water right back.
You are not even.
Okay okay.
I am getting water.
We are literally just waiting for you.
Okay I am capping right now.
Yeah look at us go.
We are nine points.
Or 25 points.
What is this?
I don't even know what to do in like this mode.
Wait have you not played this mode yet?
No I haven't played this mode.
You just it's just like capture the point.
Basically and then by the time the timer ends.
So like if a team doesn't get the required threshold.
So you can maybe try stab and look at scoreboard.
You get knocked out basically.
So like to get points you get kills and capture your zones.
And then each like I don't know how many minutes.
So like one.
After one minute and 40 seconds.
If we don't get the required points.
We basically GG.
Oh shit okay.
That is oh my god.
I am dead.
There is no fucking way.
So what the fuck are we going to play if we can't play rank?
Let's play rank.
I will fuck we will rank you.
We have to.
You can't play rank together.
Yes you can.
Did they change the update?
Yeah you can only do that.
Wait really?
Yeah.
No not if you three stack.
Unless did they change it?
Because in the past you could three stack if everybody.
Are you listening to me already?
When did they change it?
They changed it again.
Last three tiers.
So like if we three stack.
You can be like bronze.
You can only play with gold to die.
Are you?
Okay RPR just de-rank real quick for us.
Why is the hero in your chat saying.
You still can I think.
When this fucking dumbass idiot.
Asked me the same question yesterday in chat.
And I explained it to him.
And he's still fucking saying that you can.
When you can.
Okay maybe like maybe he tried it.
And he figured out that you can.
Have you ever thought about that?
You can't.
I don't know that.
Have you tried it out?
Yes.
When?
Fucking as soon as it was updated.
What do you mean?
It was updated fucking weeks ago.
Yeah.
But like.
Is it though?
Oh shit.
I got the.
Do you not have a.
Did you have like two.
Do you have like another account?
Yeah I have other accounts.
Does Rusty have other accounts?
I'm Platinum I'm fine.
Yeah he's Plat he's fine.
You can't.
Plat can play with bronze?
Yeah.
No.
Wait.
Well try it out.
Max three tiers.
I'm pretty sure Plat can only play with silver man.
Oh really?
We'll see.
Yeah.
Silver, gold, plat.
Three tiers.
Ah.
Silver, gold, plat.
Ah got it.
Oh.
Okay.
We just can't count.
That's fine.
As soon as I get to silver.
Rusty can swap.
All right.
Yes.
It's that easy.
We're so good at problem solving.
We're not Chinese.
We're so good at problem solving guys.
I'm such a.
All right guys.
Let's search.
Let's smurf with Doki Bird and RPR.
Let's go.
Let's smurf with it.
Don't put it like that.
I'm just trying to have a good time.
I'm literally in bronze just fucking around.
All right.
We're going to boost Doki Bird today.
If anything goes wrong, it's not my fault.
What?
Fuck.
Wait.
I got to remember my other accounts.
Okay.
So this one.
You'll be getting boosted, RPR.
All right.
RPR.
Doki getting boosted.
Meet up there.
Nothing's changed.
Oh, Sapporo, Sapporo.
Yeah.
I'll be in Sapporo.
Oh, you're in Sapporo?
Yeah.
We're going to do our streams there.
Let's go.
I don't know.
I just know you went to Tokyo.
I didn't know you went to Sapporo too.
I'm going to be living in Japan.
Just going to Sapporo is going to be easy.
Oh, yeah.
By before the.
When are you going?
When are you like fully moving?
January.
January?
Oh.
We finally got the visa.
No, I didn't get the visa.
Wait, wait.
How are you?
Hey, guys.
They denied my visa, but I'm getting a different visa because they denied my other visa.
Here's my Steam code.
All right.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
This guy's lagging.
They made me wait nine months.
Yeah, I was going to say, you've been waiting for so long for that.
Shit.
It's probably you lagging.
Wait, probably.
You're right.
I was going to say, I'm probably the one lagging.
I'm at 140 ping.
I won't be surprised.
Yeah, that guy's probably like, oh, my God, this guy's lagging.
Yeah, he's TP.
I don't mind that they denied me, but fucking nine months was crazy, dude.
Yeah, it did take nine months to deny you.
Yeah, it was crazy.
Oh, God.
Hey, at least, like, you know, at least, like, at least you could head there, you know?
No.
We just.
We just apply for different visas.
It's fine.
Wait, so what visa are you applying for now?
Entertainer visa.
That was easier to get than when you get an instant visa.
Wait, what was the one before?
It was like a work visa, like a very long visa.
Also, yeah, her, like, work visas are really hard to get because they don't recognize, um, they don't recognize.
They don't recognize esports as work.
Yeah, esports or, like, content creators for, like, not entertainment, like, work visa.
Well, they do, but it's, like...
It's really difficult.
Getting a visa in Japan is like going through a checklist, and you have to, like, get a certain amount of points or you don't get it.
Like, like, for instance, like, I haven't finished my college, so I don't have a degree.
If I had a degree, even though I'm working in esports, I'm not working in what my degree is for, I would still have more points in the visa.
It makes no sense.
Oh, I see.
Got it.
That's why when I'm in Japan, I'm gonna go to a language school and get, like...
A degree?
Yeah.
A certificate, like, for Japanese, and that will boost my fucking points a lot, and then I'll just apply for...
Oh!
Wait, that's interesting.
I didn't know that.
That you have, like, there's, like, a points system for that.
That's interesting.
Hey, that means...
There's a guy right in front of me.
Oh, he's so low.
The funniest part is that I have a full-time contract ready for me.
Yeah.
But it doesn't mean shit to them.
There is, like, because you just don't have a degree.
It just doesn't follow the...
It just doesn't follow the checklist.
No, author shit as well.
It's like, they're probably not sure that esports is, like, a legitimate business and blah blah blah.
I mean, does that mean...
Wait, but then wouldn't that mean that it'll be difficult to get a...
Oh god, we gotta go in.
We gotta go in before it's captured.
Yes, I'm contested.
Get what?
Sorry, we're playing that...
We're playing the knock-ups.
Oh!
No Mario!
No Mario 9!
There's, like, 20 people on here.
Yep.
It's okay, we're second.
We're safe anyway.
Wait, doesn't that mean it's gonna be difficult for ALGS players to go get a visa again?
No, because you don't need a visa to compete in Japan.
Oh!
Okay.
So the way ALGS works, right, is...
Yeah?
You're not getting paid by the country where you're playing.
You're getting paid by ALGS.
And ALGS is stationed in NA.
Oh, so in Japan you don't need a visa to...
To play...
Most countries can visit Japan for 90 days without any visa.
Just, like, enter Japan for 90 days.
Oh, okay.
So you can just go play and then...
You're not gonna get paid in Japan.
So when you go back home, you're gonna get paid by ALGS.
Oh, so, like, only after it's over you get paid.
I'm learning a lot.
Yeah, only after...
So six months after something when they decide to pay you.
I mean, that's not any different from how...
From...
Is that different from what they do in the...
Well, in the past, so...
Yeah.
I know, like, ALGS payments takes a while.
It's a process.
Yeah, she's learning about ALGS today.
She just learned that ALGS is poor.
Okay.
He didn't have to phrase it like that.
But yeah.
ALGS is not poor.
They're just fucking dumb.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's...
That's for my VR.
That's not me.
Oh, wait.
Why are they dumb?
Oh, it's not them.
It's EA fucking locking them in fucking...
That doesn't matter, bro.
I'm not gonna talk about this on stream.
It's not per se...
It's not per se ALGS stuff.
It's EA fucking not allowing them to do all the shit they wanna do.
Say your truth.
I mean, it's not my truth to say.
I don't give a fuck, bro.
Oh, my God.
I was on high graphics.
My whole entire graphics reset itself.
Are you fucking...
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's a great...
Everything was...
I was like...
Why am I lagging?
Everything is on high!
I don't even remember...
What, like, my settings are.
I'm with you guys on Steam, dude.
Guys, I'm in the game.
Like...
Oh, my God.
This makes so much more sense now.
I was like, why am I lagging so much?
It's good that I found out now.
As I said, I don't mind being denied.
I also kind of expected it to happen.
Because it was taking so long.
I was like, we're probably going to get denied.
Since it's taking so long.
That makes sense.
Holy fuck!
Okay.
I'm just happy they already made the decision.
So we can just apply for something else.
Yeah, apply before it's too late.
Okay, let me...
I haven't even finished lowering...
I don't even remember my actual stream settings.
I don't remember my Apex settings.
It should be all low.
Yeah, but then the texture streaming, everything.
I can give you a stream chance for it.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll steal your settings.
It should be like this.
Alright.
Don't worry, RPR.
We'll add you the moment we win this game.
So then we'll be champion.
I'll be the one from the game.
The moment we win this game, we'll add you.
And then you're going to be like, Whoa, you guys got champion?
Oh, damn right we did.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, it says on the top right of your corner, unsafe.
So, sure you will.
What do you mean?
We're totally safe.
Hey, I'm 32.
I'm 37.
Oh, no.
Look at that.
I've got two kills.
Okay.
He stole my kill, but that's okay.
You guys literally lost.
No, we didn't.
Stop.
No, I needed that kill.
If we get Zeus' kill, we get it.
No, you did not.
No.
Yes.
You needed 30 points.
No, he didn't.
I'm sorry.
You don't know that.
I would have given you five.
No, you don't know that.
All right.
I literally know that.
It's okay.
We almost made it.
All right.
Okay.
Now I need to do my setting shit.
I need to fix my game.
All right.
I'm going to yoink Rustia settings real quick, guys.
Oh, yeah.
You got to swap accounts too, Rustia.
Yeah.
I'm doing it now.
All right.
Let's see.
Now I'm trying to boost Doki.
What?
Oh, wait.
No.
What do you mean?
Oh, my God.
Why?
I don't even know when my settings reset.
It's been a while since I streamed Apex.
What servers are we going to play?
That's a good question.
It's based on you guys.
Well, I don't care, really, to be fair.
But not EU.
I actually do care.
As long as it's not EU, that's fine.
All right.
Where can Rustia play?
I can play Oregon and, like, whatever, outside of EU.
Yeah.
We both don't want to play EU.
Let's play NA, then.
I don't want to play on Tokyo, dude.
All right.
Let's play NA.
Let's go.
Let's go gambling.
Where the fuck is Oregon?
Oh, there it is.
It's the West Coast at the top for me.
All right.
No.
What do you mean?
I already closed my game.
It's not letting me signing out.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Send the friend request.
No one cares where Oregon is, Donkey Bird.
No one cares.
Yes, I care.
It's my server.
I don't give a fuck.
Like, you can literally just join me because it automatically is Oregon.
I need to put my VPN on it.
You got to put your fucking VPN?
Because I don't put 300 million ping.
What do you want from me?
I don't know.
Maybe, like, adapt?
Okay.
I want to give you my VPN.
Why do I have to talk to you?
You're a professional gamer.
Ping wouldn't matter.
Uh, uh, uh, uh...
I'm not pro.
Yes, you are.
You're going to play BLGS.
That's so everyone can join that tournament.
Yeah, but you...
That means you're a professional player.
Why are you joining BLGS?
No, you're not.
You literally are not.
Like, you literally are.
Then why are you joining it?
The only thing that makes you a professional player is if you are paid to play by an org.
Yeah, aren't you paid by your org?
Not to play Apex?
No.
Then what's the point?
What's the point of what?
What's the point if you're not being paid for it?
Why did you join BLGS?
Yes.
It's like talking to a wall.
It's just like talking to a wall.
It's so exhausting.
I'm just here to wake you up.
You're not waking me up, you're pissing me off.
Yeah, you're gonna be more awake now.
No, I'm not.
I'm literally not gonna be more awake.
Wait, Rustio, what's your account thing?
Okay, nice.
I added RPR, but he hasn't accepted it.
I accepted it, dumbass.
No, you haven't.
Join me, fucking idiot.
I need to open the game.
Oh, I haven't even opened the game.
Okay, so if I open the game, what difference would it make when Rustio didn't even fucking add you yet?
Yeah, but Rustio is already in the game to add me.
No, he's not.
I'm already in the game.
I added Doki.
I'm in the game now.
Rustio's solo master?
That's right.
Rustio already added me.
Yeah, I'm already in the lobby now.
Where are you?
Yeah, where are you?
I don't care.
You guys can wait.
Oh, now he's gonna make us wait.
Wow.
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Why can't I skip this intro?
This is fucking pain.
Time to wait.
RPR is late.
Yeah, Rustio's a bro.
I don't care.
I just don't care if I'm late.
I like don't give a fuck.
Like, I genuinely don't.
Look at that.
Ever since he's gonna move to Japan, he thinks he's hot shit.
Thinks he can just be late all the time.
Well, Japanese won't be late, RPR.
Yeah, yeah.
You gotta learn to be on time.
People don't like that in Japan.
Just invite me and shut up.
I did invite you.
You didn't just join my lobby.
Oh, it's not an open lobby.
Never mind.
Lobby's not open, dumbass.
You're literally in my lobby.
Rustio, your name is wrong.
You're not even playing Solo Master.
No, he'll just drop on the other side of the map so it's technically solo.
I mean, he drops on the other side of the map and then, like, we'll figure it out from there.
What he's in... Okay.
Technically, like... Okay, but you guys are late, bro.
Holy shit.
Like, who can you guys ever be on time, bro?
What do you mean?
Look, he's always late, bro.
That is not true.
I've always been on time.
I'm always waiting for people.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true, chat.
It's not... You guys are liars.
What even is... Okay, to be fair, we're playing Bronze, so meta doesn't matter anyway.
Yeah, did you know that you should have streamed on Twitch today?
Because for every 5 subs Twitch uses random gacha amount of subs.
I heard that.
I heard, like... I remember who it was, but somebody got gifted, like, 150 subs and they got, like, 100 plus subs or something.
Extra.
Someone apparently got gifted 37 extra subs on 5 subs.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Also, apparently, IronMouse has gotten, like, over 3,000 subs from Twitch.
Oh, from the gacha shit?
Holy shit!
We just got 3!
Extra!
Wow!
Guys, guys!
I might not be streaming on Twitch right now, but guys, did you guys hear?
Nah, shut up.
Did you guys hear about the extra gacha thing?
Here, I'll link my Twitch, guys.
I can't believe you fumbled so hard and you're streaming on fucking YouTube.
Why not?
I like YouTube!
Yeah, but there's gacha on Twitch.
I usually don't care about September.
Yeah, but there's gacha.
I don't even know there's a gacha event.
You didn't even pay attention!
How do you not know there's gacha?
Like, when someone gives you 5, Twitch gives you random numbers.
So fucking fun.
I saw it.
But I was just like, alright, just another day.
How to get that passive income, I know.
Guys, look, I'm not lagging anymore!
I find my stream settings, I'm fucking fed.
I'm not lagging anymore.
Wow.
Is that fucking crazy?
Apparently you can get banned from offline gifting.
I've been offline.
My voice had offline gifting.
It's only if you're like, not.
GG.
No, it's not!
No, it's not true.
It's only if they don't know who you are.
Someone reported.
Wow!
It doesn't matter.
I have an insider on Twitch.
They know I exist.
Karma should get your ass.
It's only like that if they don't know who you are.
And they're like, who the fuck is this person that's getting...
They don't know who the fuck you are.
Yes, they do.
They don't know Twitch like that.
Yes, I do.
I'm literally Discord friends with the Twitch Rivals guy.
No, you're not.
I haven't followed him back on Twitter though, but like...
Yeah, this is Karma.
Karma's getting your ass.
Get her off Twitch.
Hashtag get Doki off Twitch.
That's fucked up.
Well, you can do like double streaming now.
I don't like double streaming though.
I don't like the splitting of the audience thing.
I feel like that's just a bit too much.
God, this skin is ugly.
Oh, really?
I know what the gacha event is now.
I just saw it now.
Yeah, the September.
You get five...
Guys, if you get five subs, you get like a gacha for like... It's great.
A five for...
X amount.
I just want to see like a high number.
I think the highest Twitch has given me was like four.
I want to see like a fucking... I want to see Twitch drop like a bomb.
Four?
What a deal.
Wait, I got level 10 train?
Let's go.
Thanks guys.
What's the highest that we got?
Because I just want to steal money from Twitch.
Wait, I have Twitch chat on my stream.
My Twitch chat showed up!
On my overlay.
I forgot I had Twitch chat on too.
Oh, wait.
Is that yours?
What are you doing?
Because I thought I was offing.
Someone said they saw a free 70 yesterday and 100 gifted.
Wait, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Imagine that.
I want to see it with my own eyes, dude.
Guys, what's the highest that we got?
That is literally scamming Twitch.
This is literally legal scamming.
Also, do you guys know about Twitch Prime?
If you guys want to scam more?
If you have a Twitch Prime, you can subscribe to your favorite Twitch streamer for free.
And my channel is slash Doki Bird at Twitch.
No one cares about Twitch Prime anymore.
It's 2020, dude.
Calm down.
I care.
How do we only get 2 for 10, bro?
Twitch is scamming us.
What the fuck is this shit?
The highest I got was 24.
What's the highest you got, RPR?
I'm telling you, I got 4.
Wow, I got 24.
This is fucking sexism.
Rocio, what's your highest?
3 now.
I just saw it, like, plus 3.
Yeah, you see?
Men don't get shit.
Fucking bullshit.
They're fighting over it.
Maybe you should just stream more.
Why is Twitch, like, giving us money?
This is not the Twitch I know.
It's Valorant, actually.
This is Valorant, actually.
Why is Twitch just giving us money just like that?
It's Valorant, I'm telling you.
That's so fucked.
They take away our money.
So it's actually Valorant giving us money, which means we're scamming Valorant.
Oh, so Valorant is sponsoring it, basically.
Yeah, we're scamming Valorant.
Look at these guys.
To be fair, Valorant, I'm going up.
What do you mean?
They're bronze, dude.
I'm going up.
If I die, I die to a bronze player.
These guys, this doesn't matter if you're bronze, they're just AFK, dude.
What are they doing?
They were just AFK hiding behind a box, dude.
Oh, shit!
Wait, I'm getting shot by his teammate.
They exist?
That guy is so good at the game.
Wait, that means there's another team down here.
I got shot there, I think.
Yeah, they were ratting them or some shit.
Like, what are they doing?
We're literally in bronze.
What do you...
Ah!
You died to a bronze player!
Res me, dude.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Next to you.
What the fuck?
Guys, if you die here...
If we die here, we're fucked.
I'm so laggy, holy shit.
I might be dead.
Goodbye.
Res, you just killed someone, dude.
Yes, I have!
I literally just killed someone.
That's my ult.
I literally just killed...
The wall doesn't revolve around you.
Yeah, I'm heading over to help him.
This guy is shooting my knockdown the entire time, bro.
Just shoot this motherfucker, Doki.
I'm literally shooting him!
So demanding for something that died to a bronze player.
I was standing still and scratching my face.
Like, hello?
He shot me and I still didn't move because I didn't think he was going to hit again.
Res me, are you going to head over, Res me?
Wait, I'm...
Doki, you win that.
They're only bronzes, dude.
You're fine.
Okay, I got two.
I don't know where the...
Where is the last guy?
He was there with all of them.
No, he's not.
I'm literally there.
I mean, I saw him.
I was crawling and I saw him.
I literally got two.
Where is the last guy?
The server is unplayable.
Maybe you're just bad.
Res and I are okay.
I'm on 250 ping and I'm lagging.
I played 250 ping!
All the time!
Did I ask?
I don't think I asked.
Well, you're complaining.
Oh my god.
Look.
If you had to play on what I'm playing, you'd be crying.
No, I won't.
That's literally EU ping.
It's not.
You don't get this on EU ping.
Yes, you do.
Yes, I do.
I'm on West Coast.
Of course I do.
No, you don't.
You just don't.
Alright, Resya, can you play 250 ping?
Will you be able to?
And you won't complain, right, Resya?
I think I'm going to complain, to be honest.
How are they resed over there?
It's not them, I'm pretty sure.
I wish I could break the fucking...
I wish I could break the zip.
And send you guys fucking flying somewhere.
And then just fucking kill you.
Nah, nah, nah.
You guys are blind.
There's a literal person next to you, you fuckers, man.
You're making me laugh so I can't aim.
That guy's one, by the way.
Did you kill the guy that was in front of us?
Did you do it?
He probably did.
He's alive.
There's one guy in there.
What the hell?
Damn.
Wait, I have a gold res.
I have a gold res.
I can res you.
They also have a gold res.
I'm back, I'm back.
I'm here.
See, I got gold res.
What's funny?
These guys are fucking playing LGS down here, guys.
You'll be fine.
It's literally one guy.
We killed his teammate.
No, there's three guys down here.
I killed... we knocked one.
It's a Newcastle rampart in the fucking horizon.
Alright, I'll go behind them.
Yeah, I was gonna end the wall.
Oh, they're running.
They're leaving on my zip.
They took your zip, yeah.
They literally left.
All of them?
Yeah.
I'm going.
Alright.
We'll watch you.
Oh, they're resing over here.
That's a different team.
Yeah, but that's still a team.
Yeah, but we don't care about it.
Almost cracked him.
Go in there, RPR.
On your right.
Behind you, Restia.
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh, he should.
He has a...
Yeah, but where's this guy's third?
I don't know.
They had a horizon.
Yeah, I think he's ratting.
I mean, they have a new castle.
So they're gonna craft.
Wow, level 12.
Thanks, guys.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Level 12 hype train.
Even though you're not serious.
He's hiding down here.
Oh, there he is.
He's below us.
I'm hiding right here.
Wait, where?
Did you find him, Restia?
Oh, he did.
Go, Solo Master!
Okay, so there's another fight over there.
Oh my god.
I am bubbles.
I don't think these people are gonna be happy.
I can't wait to get drunk later tonight to fucking heal whatever's happening here.
Aren't you having the time of your life playing with us?
Oh, they're coming.
Is he coming?
Oh, there's a bow check.
Wait, what kind of suicidal flying is this?
Wait, where?
Right below us.
Oh shit, I'm hanging over here.
I'm about to get solo cryptolted.
That means they care.
They're so scared of you.
He stole that kill from you, man.
Hey, there's a...
We can get a Kraber.
Yeah, we're definitely gonna get a Kraber now that you said that.
I'm smoking it for you.
Yeah, he can just sit there for 15 minutes.
I'm smoking it.
Alright, I'm gonna open it.
They don't know.
See, they're so stupid.
They're literally running from it.
I told you.
They're so stupid.
Oh my god.
That's not from me.
Oh, I want it.
I'll take it.
Why would you want that piece of shit?
What do you mean?
It's red.
It can't be that bad if it's red.
It's terrible.
It's worse than fucking Nemesis.
Is it worse than a vault?
There's no way.
Yes, you have a vault.
Oh, I mean...
Oh, shit.
Guys, I need... guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, I had a bow check, guys.
You got put down by a bronze player.
Yeah, I was literally the last person to get knocked by a bronze player.
Somebody else got knocked before me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One of them is cracked.
Please, please.
You got knocked by a bronze player.
Please, let's get turned around.
Oh my god.
You got shit on by two people.
RPR didn't even come and save us.
He doesn't care.
No, why would I?
I don't give a fuck about you.
He doesn't care.
Wait, I didn't die to a bronze player like RPR.
I died to a silver player.
That's different.
What the fuck is this?
Why didn't you die?
Why did you just come from behind me?
They are walking in the zone, dude.
Anyway, requeue us, bro.
Press 1.
I can't believe it.
Why is he doing here?
I did.
I literally...
Look at you read.
Open your eyes.
Good job.
You pressed 1.
Look, I died to a silver player unlike RPR.
Yeah, I just died to 3 of them.
To be fair, they were a silver masters player.
They got masters last.
Yes, they were.
My guy was.
My guy.
I literally saw his masters badge.
My guy had 14 pred badges.
You can't even fit 14 pred badges on the banner.
How would you know?
Yes, you can.
I saw it.
How would you know?
You didn't see it.
I saw it.
How would you know?
I opened your stream and stream sniped you.
No, you did not.
Yes, I did.
If you open my stream, then give 5 subs right now.
Why the fuck would I give you 5 subs?
There you go.
You see?
You didn't open my stream.
No, I did, but I just didn't want to give you money.
Nah, if you did, you should give 5 subs.
Otherwise, you can't prove a point.
You're right.
I'd rather let you win than give you my money.
There you go.
Saw one.
To me, it's equally satisfying winning or fucking getting 5 gifted.
So I'll go fuck.
He's just there with popcorn.
Yeah.
Wearing my sunglasses.
He's just enjoying his time.
Where the fuck is my name?
I was actually opening up RPL streaming.
You opened his stream.
Oh my gosh.
My chat thing isn't working for some reason.
Guys, my chat's dead.
I don't know what to do.
Guys.
Only my Twitch chat works for some reason.
People can only see my Twitch chat.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm trying to fix it.
Guys.
Guys, don't worry.
I believe in my Jumpmaster.
No, I want to stream on YouTube.
I hope they ban you on Twitch for saying that.
Okay guys, protect me.
I'm trying to fix my thing.
Guys, I'm literally AFK right now.
I'm literally AFK right now.
Guys, guys, guys.
I really need you guys to not let me die right now.
Oh yeah, for sure.
I got you.
Okay, there we go.
I'm sorry Twitch chat.
Oh hey, you guys did it.
I got P20.
What the fuck is that guy doing?
That guy's okay.
Where are they?
I don't know.
Oh, he's flesh.
Nah, nah, nah.
Bro, he's really flesh.
He's one HP.
How did you get knocked?
What do you mean there are two people?
I went straight in.
Crazy.
Okay.
Okay, so Restia, we're not gonna save RPR after this, right?
Yeah, true.
Okay, nice.
That makes you believe that I'm the one that's gonna need saving.
Restia, remember, I went in for you.
RPR was out there fucking...
I'm the one that killed the third player that was on me.
I killed him, right?
No, we didn't see that.
You guys only killed two.
We didn't see that.
We don't know what happened there.
So how would we know?
Maybe he just threw a nade at himself.
Of course he did.
You don't know that.
I know that because I fucking shot him.
What do you mean?
It's he said, she said.
It's literally not.
It's a factual statement.
It's a dumbass.
Alright, Restia, you're the deciding factor.
Who do you believe?
That's why there's three of us.
So you're the final vote.
Based on what happened, RPR did me.
I was like, I gotta save Doki.
And RPR was like, bro, I'm sitting here chilling.
Yeah, see?
I'm not gonna save her.
Why would I save her?
She's supposed to be able to win.
I came in here to help Restia.
But that's not true, dude.
What do you mean?
You were the one on the ground.
I pushed in because I saw Restia try to fight two people.
Restia was fine.
I was on top, dude.
There's a guy right here by the way.
Restia was doing fine.
He came in and just died.
I was a hero.
I was a fucking hero.
There's nothing heroic about just dying without doing any damage.
What do you mean?
I have damage right now.
How much?
I have 352.
Stop lying.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna go grab some heals though.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Oh shit!
Restia's getting smoked.
What the fuck happened?
I don't know, but he's getting smoked.
I can't go in.
There's a caustic gas here.
There's another caustic gas right here.
I need to grab this.
Look, remember who res'd you and who's walking away.
I killed two people that knocked him down.
Yeah, my bad.
My bad that I have to heal, you know?
Yeah, you should have res'd him instantly if you're a good team player.
Wait, where's the last guy?
Oh, there's a crypto coming from there.
That means he must be in here.
Good luck finding the invisible guy.
I see him, he's right here.
See?
I don't think he has it.
Oh wait, no, he does, he's blue.
Alright, RPR, go get him.
Don't tell me what to do.
Alright then, I'll keep him walking away.
If he gets knocked by him, it'll be so funny.
I got an aura on him, that's great.
Thank you guys for the level 14 hype train.
Thanks guys.
I really appreciate it.
Why are you copying my skin?
What do you mean?
I always have a pink skin.
My entire account is pink skin.
It's not your yellow, not pink.
Yeah, but my account here is all pink skin.
Choo choo.
Why does she lie all the time?
What do you mean?
I'm not a liar.
When?
Give me one example.
Just now.
How did I lie?
Five seconds ago.
How?
What did I lie in?
I'm gonna save rest here.
I literally saw you heading to that building and I was like, alright, I'm gonna save you.
And tank the whole shot.
Yeah, I was gonna go save you but I'm gonna get headshotted by a bronze.
There's people behind us.
Where are you shooting at?
Are there people behind us?
Like you just called it.
Shooting at...
I couldn't see them physically.
I was hoping you would ping in.
Like a good team player.
I literally scanned it for you.
In front of me?
No!
Hey, they're gonna jump down.
What do they want?
I thought they will.
Wait, do I not have like...
Wait, how does he see through that?
How is he seeing through that?
He's gonna be like, damn.
He's gaming.
Alright, give me your fucking shield.
I have no shields left.
That guy was weird.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
It was full on smoke, but he was hitting that shit.
Was that all of them?
With nemesis as well.
Yeah.
Yay!
Does no one carry bats in bronze?
I guess not.
Oh, I have a key!
There might be bats in the server room.
I'm not opening that shit for like years.
There might be a bat in there.
It's been a long time too.
Alright, I'm gonna open this first.
Yay!
Alright, guys.
Knock, knock.
See, there's a phoenix kit.
That's definitely a bat.
Yeah, but...
Nice.
I mean, that was pretty good for me.
I got so many upgrades for it.
Yay!
Where's the fight?
RPR?
On the right.
Where?
Do you have audio?
No.
Not on this game.
Yeah, I didn't buy any skins.
For the last two years, so...
Cause you've been buying stuff.
You've been giving respawn money so you get audio.
I can't hear a guy standing still because he's just got the Dojutsu.
He just has the bronze movement.
You know, you're not used to it.
Which is understandable.
What?
How am I getting hit?
There's a guy behind this rock.
Hey, don't get knocked.
I had the box closing and I fucking hit that shit.
Don't get knocked.
Alright, turn that shit off.
Alright, that's my ult, by the way.
Oh, I cracked two!
Let's go!
Wait, where is he?
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
Nice, I think you're dead.
Hey, who...
Rustia, where's your red armor?
I mean, I'm...
I'm like...
You're in bronze, dude.
And my two teammates are like...
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
What do you mean?
We want to get out of here as soon as possible.
Yeah, we want to get out of here!
What do you mean so you can get on your main account?
You want to be in bronze forever?
This guy just wants to prolong bronze.
He wants to farm the new players.
That's fucked, Rustia.
That's cyberbullying, Rustia.
That's fucked.
You want to make these poor Oregon players have the worst day of their lives.
Okay, let's see what's our damage now.
Our damage check.
You want a damage check?
Then why aren't you in army?
What do you mean?
You two are cyberbullying.
You didn't defend RPR.
The only way...
The only way for us to get out of bronze is to cyberbully.
Whoa!
Wait, where are you shooting at?
Over there.
Give us a zipline.
I don't have one.
I just gave you one.
You think I can just fucking get there in a second?
I had something.
I'm literally here.
I'm literally here right now.
I have a zip.
Please don't type below to bully kid in my chat.
Whoa!
Nice.
There's like people over here, by the way.
Is that Mirage clone?
Oh shit, that was.
Wait, is he...
No, I'm getting Miraged.
I'm getting Miraged, guys.
Wait, are there people on you, Ruscio?
It appears to be so.
It'll be fine, right?
I don't know which one's the real person.
I'm pushing up.
Two homies.
They're all in front of us.
There's a lot of motherfuckers over there.
There is?
No, there isn't.
Oh shit, wait, what?
There's three, at least.
There's people over here in front of me.
I got bow checked.
I'm just gonna get that guy.
Who the fuck is that dude?
Really in front of me here.
What is this raid doing?
Wait, where are they?
There's this guy that's just trying to...
That guy with the bow check is fucking Legolas, dude.
Legolas is blind.
Bro, he's shooting at me!
What do you mean?
I'm heading over.
Yeah, but did he...
Did he hit?
Yeah, he hit one shot out of four.
Oh, he's running.
He's been shooting for two minutes.
Oh, wait, he has?
Okay, now that's embarrassing, actually.
Alright.
Are they...
I'm just gonna ult them.
Are they still running?
No, okay.
Oh no, they're re-involved.
Literally one.
Nice.
Oh wait, that's my ult.
Whoops, I got hit by my own ult.
Oh.
Oh, are you both doing snake?
Yeah, I got one.
Oh, nice.
Oh, you're trying to farm damage.
I see.
You're trying to farm damage!
You're trying to farm damage now!
I see.
Why else would you use a fucking sentinel?
What do you mean?
You literally did not have a sentinel before we cyberbullied you.
You only got it after we started cyberbullying.
No, no, no.
I don't wanna have high damage.
You don't wanna have high damage?
Throw your sentinel away.
Oh, really?
Oh, I'm sorry.
There's people in the ship.
Oh, wait, no.
There are people in front of me.
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
What is he... oh.
His fucking teammate is shooting me now.
100.
88.
I'll push up.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Why the fuck am I pushing up?
What do you mean?
You didn't say anything!
Why did I just say this?
Why didn't you say this to me?
You should know this shit.
I haven't played Apex in a while!
What do you mean?
Yeah, so you forgot that if the zone is not on you, you're not supposed to run away from it?
Look, I don't have depth perception right now.
God, Spitfire's fucking long angle is rough sometimes.
Horizons is almost cracked.
He's like behind this box right now.
Yeah, he is.
Oh, he's still heading over there.
He'll be in zone, right?
Whoa!
Why is that so fast?
Oh my god, though.
Holy shit!
That was so fast!
Alright, nice.
Oh, guys!
Guys!
Oh, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I fell down!
The fucking zip was so fast!
Oh, what?
There's three dudes there.
They're playing zone.
Like, they're scared.
Oh shit, never mind.
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
We have to be out of bronze from that game.
There's no way.
Yay!
Alright, how much did Rusty have farmed from the sentinel?
In devotion.
I need that Angus run.
Unbelievable, dude.
I'm not sure.
Whoa!
Yeah, but I'm playing Pathfinder.
And everyone knows that Pathfinder and sentinel is just a perfectly normal combination.
Wait, what's there?
What do you mean I'm goofing around because we're in bronze?
We're not in bronze!
Why would you want to stay here longer?
Okay, guys, I need you guys to go back to the lobby because I'm not out of bronze yet.
I need one more win.
Okay, but you probably need to get up to gold, though.
No, we just need to get to silver so Rusty can swap and we can play plat lobbies and get challenged mentally.
And like have our neurons...
No, I'm...
I know that I'm a perfectly normal person.
What do you mean you're a bird?
You're special or what?
Look, we had to have our neurons firing, okay?
And plat, we can actually...
feel like...
things matter.
Yeah, it definitely matters in plat.
Yeah!
It matters more than bronze.
Are you trying to say Rusty doesn't matter?
Alright.
I got to challenge you and conclude that.
You literally said plat doesn't matter.
You're trying to imply plat doesn't matter, but Rusty is plat.
Rusty is not a plat player.
No, I'm a plat player.
Just because you're in plat doesn't mean you're a plat player.
Then what am I?
Literally, I'm a plat player.
You're just special.
In a bad way.
What does that mean?
I'm not in a bad way!
I'm just, you know...
You know what?
Just because you say that, I'm fucking playing Venture.
You're playing what?
Can you say that again?
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I'm playing...
What is that you're playing?
I thought it was the same thing!
What's your name again?
I'm sorry, I've been playing Overwatch.
Are you playing Venture?
Who the fuck is Venture?
Vantage!
I'm playing Vantage!
Who the fuck is Venture?
They both have the same age!
They look the same!
And their name is V!
They have a V in their name!
So I always get it confused!
So you just...
You said they're copying Apex Legends?
No, I'm saying...
I'm saying Apex...
I'm saying...
Which game was out first?
Which character was out first?
Overwatch came before Apex Legends.
Yeah, but which character came out first?
Overwatch.
I've played Overwatch, I've never heard of a character called Venture.
No, it's Vantage!
Or Venture, I mean...
Oh, you're talking about Apex.
Yeah, be specific!
You're confusing me!
Can you guys do something?
What do you want me to do?
I'm Vantage.
Shoot that guy.
I'm heading over.
There's another guy here, Rusty.
If you want to shoot this guy...
Don't worry guys, I'm here.
Don't worry, trust in me.
Where are they?
I fell down.
Wait, that's another team.
Guys, there's three people.
No, it should be just Catalyst.
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize there was this one guy.
It's like she doesn't listen on purpose.
Well, I don't listen to you.
I listen to Restia.
I'm going to stop calling.
You have to call for Restia!
He's listening.
Nope, I don't.
I literally don't.
Oh, so you don't care about Restia?
No, Restia can handle himself.
Can you, Restia?
Uh...
Yeah, I definitely can.
Who would do that to you?
Who would bully you?
Yeah, true.
Oh my god.
That's so fucked up.
That you would do this to him.
Yeah, that's so fucked up.
That you would do that to Restia.
I would never.
I can't hear you.
I literally can't hear you.
I mentally blocked you out.
All I'm saying is that even though we're yelling at each other, we're doing really well as a team.
No one's yelling at anyone.
Why do you just keep lying?
What do you mean?
There's just a...
In my head, I'm yelling at you.
Alright, I am...
That means you're a mentalist.
There's so many people at Estates, by the way.
Just kill them.
Oh my god.
That's so many kills.
Go.
In the car.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
RPR left us.
You bitch.
You're such a whore.
You're actually a fucking whore.
Rusty, are you going to let him do that to me?
I'm on the car with him.
I hope you guys die in that fight.
Oh my god.
Rusty, you're literally going to die because of that.
That's fucking karma.
That's literally karma.
I don't care if it's worth it.
If you die, it's still worth it.
I am taking fire, friends.
Rope that enemy shield.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
What?
Where the fuck did this guy come from?
Oh, guys!
There's literally a team right behind you guys.
I killed.
Alright, there's like a full team right behind you guys, by the way.
I killed those guys.
You killed the lifeline and Sheila?
Yeah, that's the wrong part, but I know the lifeline.
I mean, he was holding a Sheila.
Lifeline cannot hold a Sheila.
No, the lifeline...
The lifeline and the girl that held the Sheila.
The girl who held the Sheila.
That's the wrong part, by the way.
Yeah, yeah!
That's literally... I'm just saying it in faster language.
No, it's Reaper from Overwatch.
Yeah.
True.
Alright, I'm going to scav.
Wait, there's people right behind us.
Come if you want.
Good.
Shoot them.
I am shooting them.
What the fuck are you guys doing?
Kill them, then.
Alright.
I'm wondering why you haven't knocked anyone yet.
Because I'm watching Restia.
There you go.
She's kill stealing, dude.
She just KS'd so hard.
Oh, what are you doing?
Damn, why are you not fucking helping him?
Why are you not helping him?
Because Restia said he can take care of himself.
So I want to see him take care of himself.
And save people.
I literally saved you from two of them.
What do you mean?
You did not help at all.
I literally saw you watch him get shit on.
Yeah, but I didn't say I was going to help.
And you keep saying how you're helping him.
There's another team, there's another team.
White armor, white armor.
You're literally white armor.
On me.
Knocked one of them.
Alright, you guys win your ones.
Last one.
Who hasn't won their ones yet?
I'll P20.
See?
That's so easy.
We're going to be out of silver in no time, guys.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's going to be my first time in silver.
Thanks guys for boosting me.
Yeah.
No.
Damn.
RPO is a booster, you guys.
You think that offends me or something?
By the way, I just realized there's a bug with P20 By the way, I just realized there's a bug with P20 where I had two P20s, but only one where I had two P20s, but only one was being held in my hand.
So I was only shooting one P20.
Oh, so you did the thing where you just swap it back to one.
No.
Yeah.
You can't just swap it back to one.
Yes, you can.
If you press B, it's one gun.
No.
Yes, it is.
Where's your red armor?
What do you mean?
It was a bug with the fucking car.
Where if you take the car, when you get off the car, you have only one gun in your hand for some reason.
Oh, that's weird.
I know you guys can swap it, but that's not what I did, motherfuckers.
Hit him?
Guys, we should kill that drone that's just flying around.
There's a guy that's just looking at...
Oh no, that's just a...
Magnum right there.
What is that guy doing on Pornhub?
Go, Restia, go!
Go, Restia!
You got this!
I missed every shot, by the way, but you got it.
Yeah, we know.
You were shooting him too.
It wasn't just me.
Yeah, but I didn't miss.
Yes, you did.
Oh, what?
I literally didn't...
Can you hit a bullet?
I wasn't even shooting.
There we go.
Well, where's his teammate?
Healing on the right.
Alright, doing a finisher.
No, he full on left them.
These guys protected him, but he just left them.
Restia, are you safe over there?
Yeah.
See, I cared about how he was doing.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, because our full HP teammate was in so much danger.
He could have had three people suddenly show up.
You're literally the guy in school after you bully a guy, are you okay?
Just kicked his ass and then asked me if he was okay.
Are you okay, man?
It didn't hurt that much, right?
I didn't put him in the hospital.
I gotta make sure.
I gotta make sure I'm not liable illegally.
Hey, I'm kill leader.
How the fuck did that happen?
I don't know.
Somebody wasn't shooting your gun, I guess.
No, someone's been KSing.
10 assist boys.
Wait, how many assists do you have, RPR?
Five.
Oh, okay.
So I've been kill stealing from you.
Where the fuck are the...
Oh, wait, I can scan them.
Oh, technically you can both scan.
Go do your job, RPR.
Yeah, but you should do it.
Why should I do it?
Because I'm not gonna do it.
You're literally Pathfinder.
Yeah, I'm not gonna do it.
I'm jumping.
She did something useful.
Oh shit, there's a red.
Kill him then.
He knows.
Oh, look at that poor...
Oh my god, that poor guy.
Wait, he fucking...
He literally made...
Okay, that's too much.
I'm gonna go the other side and fucking wait for him there.
I'm gonna go over there.
Wait, do you need us over there, RPR?
Are you fine?
We should be fine.
Alright, we're gonna kill this rat then.
Hey, check with that pack.
Oh, Kraber, get it!
Get it, Aristea.
That's what I'm getting.
I'm gonna help this GG.
Where's that...
Where is this...
Ash?
He should be back here.
Right?
Oh shit.
I don't know.
He's on the map.
Guys, guys, guys, guys!
He fucking surprised me!
He's literally won!
I'm coming now.
He's healing.
He shot first!
What was I supposed to do?
I don't know.
Fucking win.
Bro, he shot first!
He had the advantage!
Oh my god, she got full fend as well.
All I'm saying is I thought Aristea was with me.
It's not Aristea's fault.
It's not Aristea's fault?
Aristea, you can't win with this woman.
It's always gonna be your fault.
You should never be on her side, ever.
Alright, nice.
Can't believe it.
Wait, Aristea.
Wait a minute.
Aristea, are you okay?
Aristea, are you...
Oh, nice!
Okay.
That should be fine.
That's fine.
I gotta go.
I can't even grab my loot back.
Bro, that guy fucked me up.
It's okay.
I still have my ult, weapon, and...
I get scrabered and continues to stand still.
Oh, Devotion.
Where's that?
Wait, I want that.
Is that full team?
Yes.
Alright, you'll be fine, right?
I'm waiting for this package.
Because I don't have anything.
Hey, they're sort of looking at you.
Oh!
I just dive in a wall.
What the hell is that even possible?
Oh, he's coming down.
Alright, I'm gonna go BRB.
You guys win this.
What?
You keep crawling!
Alright.
Crawl to us!
Okay.
I'll throw you a jump pad.
I think he tabbed out.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
I think he's tabbed out.
I'm gonna jump pad.
We're gonna rez you.
Don't worry.
They're looking at me.
So, we'll be fine.
Oh my god.
What?
What happened?
I can't do fucking guard jump pad.
Good to see you guys.
Okay.
I'm fucked, guys.
Did you?
Okay, you have a jump pad.
That's good.
Just take the jump pad if you can.
I'm dead.
No!
It should be easy.
What do you mean I'm unfettered?
Just hit all your shots.
Oh my god.
I don't even have anything.
I don't have heals.
I didn't get to loot.
Oh my god.
Guys, guys.
Why did you put me in this situation?
This is my last shield cell.
This is literally my last shield cell.
Why are you not pushing me?
You know what?
No!
I can't see.
I literally can't see.
Okay, I blame RPR for that last ego push.
Hit all your shots.
Just don't miss.
It's that easy.
Wait, I think he actually left left.
He's not even...
He went to a bathroom.
He really left.
Guys, if we won that game, I would have been silver, guys.
That's all I'm saying.
Yeah,
if we get blamed for smurfing, it's RPR's fault.
We didn't want to be in this elo.
We wanted to play plat.
Lobbies.
We wanted to be in plat lobbies.
But RPR insisted on fighting against bronze players because he wants to feel good about himself.
Right, Restio?
Yeah.
You still remember if anything happens?
That's true.
It's RPR's fault.
Yeah.
It's true.
And he blamed me for starting that when you're the one that invented it.
Yeah, that's true.
He blamed me.
Even though you're the one that fucking invented the whole RPR's fault.
Well, RPR's late.
It's definitely his fault.
Exactly.
I 100% agree with you.
I want to play here.
I'm gonna go...
I'll definitely go with Tracer.
Yeah, that's basically...
Yeah, true.
True.
I haven't played Horizon in a long time.
She actually looks like Tracer.
Tracer, but Irish.
Or Scottish?
No, she's Scottish, right?
I don't remember.
I think Scottish, yeah.
It's been so long.
Wait, this guy is not back.
No, I don't think so.
Like, what the fuck is he doing?
Is he in the bathroom?
Did he have like a stomach ache or some shit?
Hello, RPR?
RPR!
Okay, why don't we both just solo launch and then leave him?
And then break this guy, yeah.
Where do we land?
We're landing here.
Okay, let's go.
Goodbye, RPR.
It's okay.
If we both die, we'll just watch this.
Watch this.
He literally left.
He literally, so he was purposely feeding.
No, you're not.
What is wrong with you guys?
What do you mean?
It literally automatically gave it to you.
You gave it to me 100%.
We didn't give jack shit.
You automatically got it.
I should not have jump master.
And you lying.
Okay, Rustia, back me up here.
Back me up.
You back her up.
We're not friends anymore.
Oh my god.
Rustia, who do you want as a friend?
Me or RPR?
You're gonna see me in Japan.
You won't see her in there.
Okay, don't worry, Rustia.
I'm coming over to help you.
Don't worry.
Who do you trust more?
You know, the one that was AFK couldn't help you or the one that wasn't AFK still didn't help you?
I had to get a gun.
That's all I can say.
I didn't have a gun.
No, there wasn't.
Now there is.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I think I might be dead.
You're fine.
You're not fine.
Fuck!
Why are there people here?
Why are they there?
All I'm gonna say is I knocked you.
All I'm saying is where the fuck...
All I'm saying is that I got fucking...
I got fucking ran out by three different people.
I couldn't even shoot my gun at that point.
Three people just showed up.
All I'm saying is that if RPR landed with us, this wouldn't have happened.
Rustia wouldn't have died.
Only the person...
If only the person that landed with Rustia actually fought with Rustia, that would have been great.
I did not get a gun.
So I had to run to a place with a gun.
That POI is massive.
No, no, no.
That POI is not big enough.
There were like five teams.
You gave me Jump Master while I was AFK.
We did not give you Jump Master.
That's not true.
You gave me Jump Master while I was AFK.
We did not give you Jump Master.
No way.
He needed you.
It's RPR's fault and Doki is lying.
What is true and it's not the part about me.
I'd never die on the internet, guys.
That's a sin.
That's a sin and I'm not a sinner.
You're definitely a sinner.
You will go to hell.
Then I'll meet you there.
I'm going there.
You'll be there first.
Or you'll welcome me to hell.
That phrase was so powerful.
You're going to hell.
I'm volunteering to go first.
How is there no gun in this game?
I lost it.
You should back.
I don't do boxing.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
I'm fucking.
Oh, I forgot.
I'm a mad Maggie.
Mad Maggie.
I don't know why.
This guy is just a goat.
How did you die?
I don't know because maybe I don't have a gun.
There's like five guys.
Oh, yeah, yeah, like how I didn't have a gun either.
Yeah, but the POI is soooo big.
Whoa, that was such a big POI.
Lucky, what are you doing with that alternator?
I'm freaking trying to heal, what do you mean?
Oh, are you serious?
What the fuck, there's two of them?!
Why?!
This guy is literally not doing anything with his team.
I remember getting to silver.
He hit there in the corner.
Holy shit.
Why he didn't do anything for his team, he literally just hit there in the corner.
Why are you making fun of a silver player or a bronze player even worse?
What do you mean?
I was saying he was in the corner just hiding there without helping his teammate until I fucking killed him.
He fucking popped over.
It's okay.
It's because...
For some reason, our pair couldn't get a gun even though the POI is so big.
Someone really shit POI.
Oh, you're blaming Restia.
He was the gentleman.
It was definitely you.
Like 500 houses there to get a...
Yeah.
Why did you land over there?
Oh, no comment.
Now, there's no comment because he knows he's wrong.
I'm not wrong.
I'm literally not wrong.
You literally blame Restia for jump mastering.
Even though his jump mastering was okay.
I'm literally the only one here who can qualify as a pro player.
That makes me the most right here.
That's not true.
Restia is also technically a pro because he...
No, he's not.
Technically, he is.
He got...
He got disqualified.
He got disqualified for being a pro.
Yeah, but you played in one LGS event.
If one LGS event makes you a pro, then everyone and their mom is a fucking pro player.
Oh, so you don't respect Restia and his achievements.
No.
I didn't say that.
I just said he needs to be in the pro league.
Whoa.
To be a pro.
It's okay.
You just get your ass carried by Krillix.
You think that's like an insult or something?
That's literally why I added him into the fucking team though, man.
Restia, don't worry.
I'm handing over to you.
RPR fucking left you, but I'm handing over.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just one shot, but I'll stay there.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay.
Saved.
Damn.
Wait, who's IGL in your team?
You or Yuris?
You're not going to let Yuris?
Why would you use IGL?
Cause isn't he IGL in his last team?
Wait, they're rezzing?
You think he enjoys OGLing?
Fucking no.
I never asked him if he enjoyed it.
Yeah, literally every time it turned into their scrims, it's like RPR on the ground, RPR on the ground.
Oh, my God.
That is not even true.
That happened once.
Now, I know that you're just lying out of your ass.
Now, I just know that you're not even watching.
Because there have been like hundreds of instances where I actually fucking did more damage and both of my fucking teammates are supposed to be carrying me.
Oh, look at that.
Arpio did not help us in this fight too, classic.
I don't need to help you.
Why would you need help in Bronze?
I don't know, because we're a team and we're supposed to fight as a team.
We're not a team.
We're enemies.
We're literally in the same party.
We're literally enemies.
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
Oh, hey, Fireball.
Okay, I haven't played Magnum in a long time.
Why the fuck would you reuse IGL over me?
What?
I don't know, because your use is a decent IGL.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah, and I'm...
Well, he's younger too, so...
So what, just younger me because you're better at IGL?
You're like fucking dumb.
That's the best words I can find for you.
You're dumb.
All I'm saying is that I don't know.
Have you guys tried who's like the better IGL?
I don't know.
Maybe because, you know, your use never even qualified for a LAN, and I've actually been fucking to every single LAN when I play professionally.
IGL is gross.
He's getting receipts.
Damn, damn.
Maybe just that.
I mean, hey, if you're going to talk shit, you need to have, you know, results to back Wow, I didn't talk shit.
I was just giving suggestions.
Yes, you did.
You literally did talk shit.
I was giving suggestions.
I wasn't talking shit like...
Why would I take suggestions from you?
Ask yourself that.
Why would you give me suggestions?
I'm just saying maybe give Yuris a chance.
You died to Bronzies.
You died to Bronz too.
You literally died more than me to Bronz players.
You're saying give Yuris a chance like Yuris even wants to IGL.
You don't know that, baby.
People want IGL in this game.
That's true.
IGL is so fucking... a lot.
Yeah, I saw your tone, IGL-ing Doki.
IGL-ing is too much.
It's not fun at all.
It's fun for me because I know how to do it.
Because maybe you just hate yourself.
No, it's just easy for me.
All right.
Let's see where you place in BLGS.
You know, after 40 years of talking to his like grandchild.
I was a Europe champion 50 years ago.
Holy shit.
You're so dumb.
Damn.
Apex champion.
And you're a European champion 50 years ago.
I did a lot more than just win one tournament.
You know that.
Damn.
Really?
Like what?
I mean, you keep bragging about the EU LGS, but like, what about the others?
I didn't even bring up the EU LGS.
Yes, you did.
You literally brought it up.
I literally did not bring it up.
You brought it up to Rusty and saying that he's not a pro player.
You were like Rusty is not a pro player because he didn't win an EU LGS like me.
Of course he's not in pro league.
You just fucking hear what you want to hear.
I said he's not a pro player because he's not in the pro league.
That's literally what I said.
Never even brought up the fucking EU LGS in a championship.
Whoa, shit.
He died to a bronze.
Like he actually brain dead.
We're trying to save your life right now, RPR.
You got to calm down.
I don't give a fuck.
Let me die.
We're trying to save you.
Take the jump pad.
I'm not on your team anyway.
No, I'm taking it into them.
What do you mean?
Why did you fucking miss it?
Oh my god.
I don't want to get rushed by you.
I'll play this team now.
Oh my god.
Bro, he's one.
Oh, this is bad.
Let's take one.
I'm fucking backing out because I need a heal.
I need a Phoenix Kit.
Is this one team or two?
Two.
Frisia?
Oh, my god.
I'm in it.
Just one guy.
You should go in there.
It's just one guy.
It's not one guy and you fucking know it.
It is just one guy.
Okay.
Guys, I don't think this was one guy, guys.
I don't think this was one guy, guys.
I didn't finish my party though.
Like after like, I tried to talk to this great job.
Oh.
Champion, 50 years ago, his grandchild would be like, but grandpa, I heard your ass was carried by Mande.
Yeah, because Mande did so great without me when he played LGS after.
He makes more money as a content creator, so he doesn't care about LGS, right?
So do I.
Why do you think I'm not playing?
No, you're playing BLGS.
They're not playing in BLGS for money.
Because there isn't any.
Wait, no, there is if you make it.
I thought there was money, what?
Yeah, it's like 100k a region.
There's like nothing when you split up on those teams.
And they're amongst the players.
Damn, so you're just doing this for pleasure and content.
What do you get for winning?
Like, what do you get?
If you win BLGS, I'm guessing first place gets like 30k or something.
You get to be on Nice Wigs stream.
Yeah, but I'm telling you I'm not playing for money.
You don't want to be on Nice Wigs stream?
You started talking about money and I'm telling you I'm not playing for the money because you can't really win that much there.
Yeah, but I didn't just say it's just money.
I'm saying there's fame and exposure.
What fame can I get from BLGS?
I played in ALGS last.
Nice Wigs!
What fame can I get from BLGS?
What about Nice Wigs?
And Restia is going to watch your stream.
He's going to watch part of your team.
Yeah, I'm going to see you rage.
Yeah.
I never raged during comp and you should know this if you actually watched me play ever.
Yeah, you never rage in comp.
You still complain though.
What is this team doing?
What do you mean?
I mean, if a stupid team does something stupid, you scream.
They should be called out.
Give us examples.
Give us examples of your teammates being stupid if you are.
I didn't say my teammates.
I said the team.
If a team is stupid, you should call them out because they're never going to get better.
Okay, then call us out.
You don't call us out.
Do you not want us to improve?
I don't care if you get better though.
Not even Restia?
Restia doesn't need me.
You hear that?
Yep.
Restia was an Overwatch pro.
Why can't he get better by himself?
I saved your life.
You're welcome.
You didn't.
You literally are the only one who has armor cracked.
You stole my kill.
I didn't even get hit once and you had armor cracked.
Maybe you should make sure you have cover too.
Maybe you should get cover when you're trying to fight somebody.
How many kills did you get?
I have two.
Why is she lying all the time?
I literally have two.
I will stop and screenshot my kills right now.
Just open up my stream.
Open up my stream right now.
I'm not giving you a viewer.
Open up my stream and give me a plus one viewership.
RBS chat, open up my stream to confirm it for him and then you can say I'm right.
I'm not giving you a viewer.
Yeah, but your chat's going to give me a viewer.
Yeah.
The funny part is that RBS chat's going to turn on him.
My chat loves me now.
We're in a different era.
You're in a different era?
What happened?
Yeah, we're different now.
There's actual character growth?
I don't know.
Ever since I started playing BLGS, they love me now.
I don't know what's happened.
BLGS hasn't even started yet.
Yeah, we've been screaming.
Yeah, because they love your recent Gryllix.
No, they've been nice to me.
I don't know why.
Really?
Chat's heart's beating.
Chat, you're spamming like old man RPR now.
It starts spamming RPR's vote.
Why do you think that insults me?
It proves our point.
You're saying they respect you.
If they respect you, they won't spam it.
If you tell chat to start spamming anything, they'll spam it.
So your chat doesn't have free will?
They can decide on their own.
No, no, I said that.
The streamer says, chat spam this.
They always fucking do it in any fucking chat in any Twitch stream anywhere like what?
No, that's not true.
My chat didn't spam it because I didn't tell them to.
I get it.
Yeah, but if you told them they would, like are you dumb?
Please choose to spam.
It's the streamer's fault and our PR's fault.
Wait, are you?
He's literally older.
But I look younger.
Okay, literally having a beard makes me a little older.
You're also fucking Asian.
It doesn't count.
Whoa!
It doesn't count, dude.
That's fucked.
Wow, you pulled a race card.
That's weird, bro.
That's awkward.
I wish you... sometimes I really wish you weren't dumb.
I really wish.
But it's just like, it's not gonna happen.
If I'm dumb, then why do people love watching me?
Because... I'm not gonna say it.
I'm not gonna insult your fanbase.
Wow!
What are you gonna say, huh?
My fans are your fans, too.
What are you gonna say?
They feel sorry for you.
That's why they watch you.
They feel sorry?
People love watching dumb people.
Okay, wait.
That's true.
That's why sometimes I watch RPR, too.
Why did you say I was... I zoned you out?
It's okay.
It's not... It doesn't matter to you.
It literally doesn't.
You're right.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
Exactly.
Just be ignorant.
That's why we love watching you.
I bet your chat agrees with me that you're dumb.
No, they don't.
Let me check.
If you're a Doki viewer, come into my chat and tell me if you agree or not.
No, no.
If you're a Doki viewer, do not go to his fucking chat.
If you're a Doki viewer, come into my chat and tell me if you agree if Doki is dumb or not.
Wow!
Wait, I'm actually his model, so I'm gonna make a poll and...
Oh, that's true!
Yeah!
Let's make a poll.
Bro, yeah, I can make a poll, too.
I can make a poll, too, on my own channel.
Yeah, but Doki, everyone and their mom knows that your polls are rigged from day one whenever you make one.
That is not true.
Absolute rigged.
How are they rigged?
They're the same polls as a Twitch poll.
It's just on a different platform.
How are they rigged?
You're the one that rigs them.
What are you on about?
Why do I rig it?
You always rig them.
I gotta say, Doki's in the lead on who's the number of polls, like 74%.
Right now, it's 74% on Doki, 25% on RPR, and may I remind you...
That's not true.
You guys...
...that my chat are all hate watchers.
And they're all still on my side.
That's fucked, bro.
That's your fucking chat.
Yeah, but you know what my... You know that my chats are like...
We had a VR chat group that was called Shinidachi, which was our name.
We renamed it to RPR Hate Watchers.
WOOOOOOAH This guy is the GOAT.
Up here, what the fuck happened?
You can't let this happen in BLGS.
Don't worry.
Anyway, I'm winning this poll, so I don't care.
Where is he?
Where is the guy?
I am a dragoon, and Doki's definitely dumber, but that is why we love her.
Are you gonna kill the guy that just knocked me?
Or you just gonna pretend like...
WOOOOOOAH WHAT THE FUCK?
Wait, Restia's losing his- WHAT IS GOING ON RESTIA WHAT THE- I'm 100% sure about this.
We're going to the lobby, dude.
I can't hear them.
Behind you.
What happened?
This guy is a goat.
You don't understand.
Alright.
Where is he?
Below me.
What?
How did he get over here?
I'm telling you, this guy...
I don't know what he ate this morning.
I don't know what he ate this morning, but he is the goat of Mozambique.
Maybe you should recruit him.
Maybe he should be on your team.
Might as well recruit him.
I mean, he literally beat you and Restier, so you might as well be on your team, right?
Yeah, but you haven't seen Kralix, dude.
Kralix would beat us both as well.
That's true.
He is younger too.
He has the reflexes to make up for it.
You know, the rest of the team.
I have one guy singing in my team, one guy singing Filipino rap, and the other guy killing everyone.
And I have to babysit both of them.
That's my team.
That sounds fun.
What's wrong with that?
That sounds so fun.
Until you need to get them both to shut the fuck up and actually tell them what to do.
Holy fuck.
Those motherfuckers, when they start yapping...
Yeah, we're training you for it.
Yeah, Restier and I are training for you.
When Kralix starts on his fucking bullshit, dude, I need to fight him to fucking get awarded.
Oh my god.
Hey guys, we're gonna be silver!
It's crazy.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Also, my poll says they think you're dumb.
You're dumber than me.
So, I don't know.
Yeah, is RPR dumb?
Yes or no is your poll.
Yeah, but if they vote no, then that implies...
Yeah, but why didn't you make the poll, who's dumber, RPR or Doki, and then see what happens?
No, because I already...
So, you rigged the poll again.
How did I rig the poll?
That was the answer.
That was literally the question.
You rigged the poll again.
How did I rig it?
It just goes to show.
It's called democracy right there.
Yes or no.
A good question should be a yes or no question.
That's a good question.
That only gives your chat the ability to say yes or no, nothing else.
No opinion.
I have an honest opinion.
So, you should make a poll on is Doki dumb?
Yes or no?
Yeah, do that.
Do that.
Make that poll.
Alright, fine.
I'll do it.
Alright, make that poll.
Yeah, I'm gonna do it.
What are you doing?
Why are you just standing there?
Why are you just standing there, RPR?
There's a team right in front of us.
I'm waiting for your poll to appear in chat.
Look at that.
Not even a team player.
There's literally...
I'm literally waiting for... I'm not moving until there's a poll in your chat.
Oh, it's the fucking reset.
Like what?
That thing reset is...
I'm not moving until you make a poll in your chat.
There's literally a team in front of Restia.
We gotta help him and I'm a team player.
Look at that.
Good job, Restia.
Don't I have a mod in your chat?
Maybe I can do a poll.
No, you don't.
Mods can't do polls in non-eat.
YouTube sucks.
This is why YouTube sucks us.
I love YouTube.
It doesn't mean that, guys.
Oh my god!
Your entire chat is asking for this poll, by the way.
But they're not.
Don't speak from my chat.
What the fuck?
I'm reading your chat right now.
I'm in a fight.
I can't... I can't see it.
Wait, there's a red... near us.
What the fuck is this guy doing?
He thinks we won't break the door just to kill him?
Wait, there's a red next to us.
Ooh, there's Kraber.
Whoa!
Grab it!
Okay, I'll take it then.
Oh, right here.
There's a team right in front of me.
Whoa!
It's a full team.
They're in this house.
Oh, he's running.
Got what?
Whoa!
Bro, chill, chill, chill.
Here's a thing for you.
You got... okay.
Oh, 150.
Where is he?
He's red.
Here, here, here.
He's low.
Okay, I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, he was low.
What is RPR doing?
He's actually looking at your pole.
I'm waiting for your pole.
I'm literally trying to save Rusty's life!
I already armor swapped it.
I don't know, actually.
I know I knocked the other guy, so he has to heal.
I hope, like, the zone kills him.
He's cracked.
Wait, I got hit by another squad here.
Damn, you really hate that guy.
Yep.
Waku waku.
I can't believe RPR would just throw... throw a game like that.
Wait.
He came from here.
Oh, he's there, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Rusty and I are good teammates.
We have...
Wait, who are you shooting at?
Oh!
I was like, wait a minute.
Who am I shooting at then?
Oh, we have a creeper.
Guys, look, we have the pole when we... when we kill this team.
RPR, if you wanna have a pole, you gotta come over here and help us kill this team.
No, I'm fighting a different team.
No, you're not.
You're literally standing there.
I can... I can see you...
I can fight while standing still.
I see you just standing there.
I'm shooting.
Oh, my God.
I missed every shot.
It's fine.
I... I threw a ball at them.
Oh, I hit them.
In this game, it's harder to shoot while you're standing still than when you're moving.
What?
Who told you that?
What do you mean?
When you move, you have... you have less fucking recoil.
There's like a mirage over here.
Oh, shit!
Nice!
Over here.
Oh, wait, no.
That's a mirage.
Oh, my gosh.
Where are they?
Surely two masters of red armor players can handle this.
Restia is not doing...
Oh, no!
What the fuck?
Okay!
Oh, okay.
Hey, RPR, there... he's hiding.
So, what happened?
Oh, I don't know.
We had to 2v3.
I don't...
I feel like you guys should be able to 2v3 in...
I got flanked.
Restia got flanked too.
In a fucking silver lobby.
Yeah, but a flank is a flank.
That's all.
You should 1v2 here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're a master.
You should be able to 1v2, right?
You should be able to 1v2.
Yeah, you should 1v2.
Yeah.
I got my 1.
But no, you guys didn't even get a 1.
What are we on about?
Yes, we did.
They rez.
You guys didn't even kill a single guy.
It's 3.
You guys are lying as well.
Wow.
RPR.
This is a silver lobby, RPR.
I just watched the kill for the entire time.
Yes, I can't make a poll because he didn't help us.
You didn't kill a single person.
I did say I'll make the poll if he helps us with this team, but look at what happened.
You guys are so bad.
Remember, chat, this is RPR's fault for not helping us with the team.
You guys are bad.
I was AFK for 30 minutes and I still almost had as much damage as you guys.
This is embarrassing.
I don't know what you're talking about.
You literally can't even break 1k.
That's so fucking embarrassing.
You literally didn't even break 1k.
I was standing still for three zones.
Three zones.
You would have at least broken 1k before you stand still, but you still...
That means you had even less damage when you got involved.
That means I had more damage than you because you guys were fighting like four teams while I was standing still.
That means you had 700 damage.
One team.
Doki grieved by not making the poll.
Agreed.
We could have won that game if you made the poll.
Like, we could have won the game if you made the poll.
All you have to do is make the poll.
Well, I said you gotta come over here and help us out and then I'll make the poll, but you didn't come over here, so that's your fault.
That's not how life works.
That was my condition.
You have to make the poll for me to move.
I'll make the poll because I am a humble person who is willing...
Sure you are.
...who is willing...
Yeah, yeah.
...to be nice...
You're definitely humble, very humble.
...to my chat.
Oh my god.
Which I know RPR's chat doesn't have, never had that feeling before.
Yeah, I'm just never actually learned from that.
Cause I know, I know like RPR's chat, you guys never had that feeling before or like felt that?
Came over from Dokie stream, can't handle anti-democratic streamers.
Just saying.
That's a message in my channel.
76% on this DokiDom, yes.
That means we're both dumb!
Because they think you're dumb too, RPR!
Yeah, but in my chat...
At least we're both dumb!
Yeah, but your chat's biased!
No, it's not.
If you know my chat, you know they're not biased.
I thought you said your chat...
I thought you said your chat is nice to you now!
My chat is filled with hate watchers who vote against me.
You know something's wrong.
Oh, so now they're hate watchers.
Changing the fucking story!
No, that's the point.
I was briefly in RPR's stream and never felt so unwelcome.
So comfy in Doki's stream!
Yeah!
Stay there then, motherfucker!
Also, thanks for the super chat, I really appreciate it!
Keep that guy, please!
You know which chat I feel the most comfy in?
Rusty's chat.
Yep.
There's a guy coming over to you.
There's a guy coming over to you right now.
I knocked an old man over there behind us.
Nice.
I warned you.
I'm a hero.
She's not a fucking hero.
You know we're even close.
I literally gave Rusty an intel.
Yeah, but he killed him.
Yeah, but I gave him intel for it.
Like that.
We killed a team.
Backwards ass logic.
Oh, I'm getting shot at from here.
Cracked him?
Oh, I got you.
Go away, Rusty!
What the hell?
What the fuck?
There's a guy behind me.
What the hell?
You got this.
He's coming in, by the way.
Don't worry.
I know that RP has got it.
Because I believe in him.
No, you don't.
Yes, I do.
I'm literally not heading over.
Just because of how much I believe in you.
Wait, where are they?
Why are you lying?
It's one guy.
It was not one guy.
Why are you lying?
I saw one guy.
You literally got Rusty and I killed!
Nah, you're stupid.
They're both one, by the way.
They're literally both one.
Oh my god.
That's so embarrassing.
Wow.
Just because I saw one guy doesn't mean there is one guy.
It's over now.
Alright, Rusty, let's go to plat.
Let's go to plat lobby.
Oh man, plat lobby is going to be so cool.
How did RPR lose that?
Rusty and I both got them one!
That's crazy.
That's okay.
You know, RPR, it's okay.
You know, years can do that to you.
The older you get, the less...
Why do you think I care?
Do you really think I care?
I don't care.
I don't care we die.
Why are you so defensive?
You don't have to do this team play shit.
I don't care.
But we're a team.
I hope we die again in plat 2.
At least you don't care.
As long as you're suffering, I'm winning.
Hold on.
Watch the world burn.
Damn.
What happened to you?
When did you get so pessimistic?
Pessimistic?
What is pessimistic?
I just don't want to win.
That's exactly what it is!
What happened?
It's not pessimistic.
I just don't want you to win.
Why not?
But we're a team.
We're not a team.
We're a team.
We are not a team.
Rusty and I are a team.
Yeah, and I'm not part of your team.
What?
You don't like Rusty?
Invite me, invite me.
Alright.
Well, he's on your team, so that means he's against me.
I'm not.
I'm like...
I'm like in center of you guys.
What is that?
Shit.
Okay, I got you.
I invited you.
Damn.
Yeah, this was Rusty's idea.
I was like, who should we get as a third?
And Rusty has said, let's get RPR.
Thank you so much, Rusty.
Yeah, he did this for you.
I'm such...
Fucking asshole.
I'm such like...
Fucking RPR.
What are you gonna play?
Loba?
You're gonna play Loba and Plat?
First of all, what are you playing, Doki?
Oh wait, yeah, I'm not playing...
Now that we're in Plat.
No, no.
What do people play?
I don't even know what people play in rank.
What do they play?
Catalyst?
Oh, fucking no.
Is Catalyst still good?
I guess.
You're literally in BLGS.
What do you play for your team?
We're in rank.
We're not gonna play rank like it's BLGS.
Yeah, okay, so what do you play in rank?
What do you play in rank then?
We play the same characters we play in BLGS.
Yeah, exactly!
But we're warming up for scrims.
That's different.
You wanna play what we play in BLGS?
We play Pathfinder, Newcastle, and Bangalore.
What the fuck is that comp?
What do you mean, what's that comp?
It's like...
Is that the new meta?
Only Giga should split Pathfinder and comp.
Oh my god, that's...
It's like, you know...
You get like the bins reset, like in endzone, and Newcastle has the gold knock.
That's like super strong.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I wanna try Newcastle then.
Because you both trust in my Newcastle.
No, I'll play it.
Why not?
I just had a premonition.
What happened?
What did you have?
It just wasn't good.
I'm gonna find One Piece.
You know that they never...
They copied this One Piece skin, and they never created One Piece.
I know about it.
Everybody know it's a One Piece skin, but they...
It's a fucking Luffy skin, and they just...
Yeah, they yoinked it, and they were like...
He's just a pirate with a hat.
He's just wearing a hat.
I wonder why One Piece didn't sue them yet.
I feel like they should.
You know like the Demon Slayer stuff?
And then they have like the...
Like the clothes.
Really?
For which one?
I mean like...
There's so many goods that's related to the squares, but it's actually not a...
Not a collab.
That's funny.
They've copied so many things from anime, and I really feel like the anime industry should just all gather up and start suing Apex Legends.
Burn them to the ground.
Watch the world burn.
His opinion does not reflect this team's by the way.
I mean they deserve it.
It's literally against copyright.
Our fear does not reflect the rest.
Rusty and I, by the way, we love Apex.
We don't see any comparison between the two.
Of course you don't.
Of course not.
I love Apex.
There's like people in front of me fighting.
Oh wait, I fucking was using my mask if I didn't even see that.
On you.
He's literally looking at this team.
Oh shit, what the fuck?
You've run away.
What is wrong with you?
Yeah, he's cracked.
This guy's flesh.
I put a nade in there.
I'm heading over.
Alright, go RPR, go.
Last one?
This one's in the corner.
It's okay, you can rez him.
I know what I can do.
Whoa.
This is your warming up for your scrims.
I don't play Newcastle.
Then why are you playing...
Because I don't trust you with Newcastle.
Why don't you trust me?
You don't know that.
Do I have to elaborate that or what?
What?
Yes.
I feel like I'm a very trustworthy person.
You feel wrong.
Why are you backing me?
Why did you laugh at that?
I thought you were on my side.
I'm the balance, you know.
You're the balance.
Okay, okay.
You are dangling from the cliff, Restia.
And it's either me or...
It's either me or RPR that saves your life.
Who do you trust to save your life?
Of course I would save your life before you.
You mean of course you.
What's that supposed to fucking mean?
I'm going to look at...
Can you fucking kill this guy?
I was looking at the guy I was getting rezzed.
Restia, what happened?
Oh my god.
These two are both rezzed.
They should be broke.
I am trying to combat...
Look, I have a charge rifle.
We're good, we're good.
Alright.
I'm holding this door.
Okay.
What happened to the door?
He's a charge rifle.
He's trying to punch.
He has nothing.
No, but he's a liar.
He has a gun and a charge rifle.
You're fucking lying.
You are such a...
I have a charge rifle.
What are you on about?
He shot...
You want to know who he shot me with?
He shot me with a fucking...
He has a 301 and a charge rifle.
What are you on about?
He was like, he has a charge rifle.
Just go...
45 and RE.
He has nothing.
What's your damage, dude?
What are you doing?
Who rezzed you?
You're like baiting me.
Yeah, you baited him.
I'm baiting you.
You literally baited...
He baited me and Restia.
He literally said he has nothing.
He just has a charge rifle.
Thank you for revealing how toxic Doc is.
First time shot her.
I'm not even doing anything.
She's just self-exposing.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm the most trustworthy person out there.
In this group.
Actually, no.
Actually...
Not even...
Cause I trust Restia more.
Cause he's a cat.
You're not even the most trustworthy person if you were alone by yourself in a lobby.
That's not true.
I'm more trustworthy than you.
We both know that's not true.
I said...
Restia, you're about to die.
But only one of us can save you.
Who would you pick?
Probably let me die.
Look at that.
He doesn't even trust you, RPR.
He knows I would save him.
Do you?
Do you, Restia?
No, we actually have like...
I always have a question.
If your girlfriend, your mom, falls into the water.
Into the sea, who would you save?
Yeah, who would you save?
I don't have a girlfriend so I'd save my mom.
No, it's like...
Restia and I...
Next.
Oh, next?
Okay.
He's not even gonna...
Look at that, Restia.
He's not even gonna save you.
Yeah, he's probably just gonna watch us like...
He's just gonna watch us drown.
What was the question?
I was like...
If Restia and I are both drowning in the water.
In the ocean.
Okay, if Restia in your chat is drowning in the water.
Who would you save?
You're gonna save your entire chat collectively.
Or just Restia.
If I save chat, that's more than one people.
I would save more lives if I save chat.
So I'm saving chat.
Despite what Restia did for you?
What about what my chat did for me?
I mean, but...
Isn't Restia a bro?
Yeah, okay.
But what about my chat?
I have like...
Thousands of bros then.
Whoa!
Restia...
I'm just going by the amount of people I would save.
I would save more people if I save chat.
Or I could sacrifice my entire chat for the life of a single person.
Yeah, but he might be...
Restia wouldn't even want...
Restia wouldn't even want me to save him over hundreds of people.
Restia, do you want him to save you?
What if Croatia and the United States of America is both drowning in the water?
I'm saving Croatia every single time without fucking blinking.
Yeah, but like, the United States have more people, more population.
Yeah, but...
But it's the United States.
Your logic doesn't make sense!
Yeah!
My logic made perfect sense.
You're saying that more people saved is a better option yet you're gonna...
America needs a fucking reality check anyway.
It's all good.
No!
Okay, but what if we include N.A.
instead of just America?
I feel kinda sorry for Canada but I still save Croatia.
Oh, so you'll let your...
You'll let your Reese drown?
Your Reese is in Japan.
We're good.
Yeah, but he...
Yeah, he's Canadian!
What about his family?
His family is from the Philippines.
He's good.
He has family in Canada?
What if...
His family is from the Philippines?
His family is from the Philippines.
I've sacrificed Doki for both.
Whoa!
I'm not even in either country!
Yeah, but still.
That's good.
Damn.
That's fucked.
Oh, hey.
I need that.
Actually, I don't.
Oh, there's a...
There's a purple... What about you?
Why am I being asked these stupid questions?
Why are you guys not being asked these questions?
Because...
Because we're the one asking.
Yeah, because we're the... You're not the one asking.
You could literally ask whenever you want, but you don't.
You're just giving us this opportunity.
Sorry for making...
Oh, sorry for being content creators, RPR.
Shut up.
You're gonna make me cringe out.
Holy fuck.
There's a line I drew and you just crossed it.
Oh, sorry.
We were just trying to make some content here.
Just my content brain.
Shut the fuck up.
Where the fuck do we go?
IGL.
Where the juicer is.
IGL, tell us where to go.
If you're in IGL, you should be leading us.
I'm not in IGL.
I'm not IGL.
Why not?
You should practice.
I'm not gonna waste my IQ on fucking rank.
But you do for your team.
What do you do for your team?
I'm not playing with my team right now.
Yeah, but treat us like your team.
We're literally playing the same comp.
No.
We're playing like literally your team.
Yeah, we play octane in comp.
Yeah, we're metagaming.
We're metacrafting right now.
Yeah, my team plays...
If my team played octane in comp, I'd fucking...
We're gonna lose it.
People here.
I'm heading over, guys.
I don't know if you guys know this, but...
I'm heading over.
To help.
You know what's funny to me?
We've been doing this for how long now?
Years upon years.
And people still think I'm mad.
People still think I get mad.
If I'm a new viewer, I'd probably think you're mad.
Because you would sound mad.
If he was mad, he would've...
I just don't care.
He's already...
That's based on the voice.
Your voice is monotone-ish.
And you sound angry, but that's...
It's just because he's European.
It's because he's European, they always sound...
That is extreme discrimination.
Oh my shit.
Where are they?
I don't know.
They were just shooting you.
Oh, so you're baiting again.
Someone...
Is he angry or is he just European?
We'll find out.
So what do you have to do to not appear angry?
Like we just have to laugh all the time like you?
You just gotta be happier.
I am happy, man.
Don't assume you know what my mental state is.
That's mental assuming, dude.
Mental assuming.
That's social suicide we just did.
What did I do?
I'm just saying, you just gotta...
You just gotta be happier.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, you got knocked out.
Motherfucker booped me.
Where are you shooting at?
Oh, over there.
Oh, it's two.
Okay, we have an issue.
And the issue is that guy beaming, dude.
Which one?
I don't know.
The guy above you is beaming.
I'm bad.
I'm heading to...
He hates me.
That guy just tried to drill my fucking wall, but you can't drill a Newcastle wall because it deletes it.
That's crazy.
So he's just a hater for no reason.
Maybe he knows.
Maybe he's a stream sniper.
If he knows, why would he drill?
Because, you know, he never plays against Newcastle.
So he thinks that's how it goes.
I'm literally in plat.
Don't assume what plat players think.
Then he doesn't know.
Then don't say maybe he knows.
He doesn't know then.
I said maybe he knows that you're there.
So that's why he drilled it.
Because he's a stream sniper.
You didn't let me finish my sentence.
He didn't listen to what I said to begin with.
There's people up here.
I'm 69 EVO from purple.
So?
69.
You're not dying in three seconds.
What's that mean?
3, 2, 1.
That means?
I'm here.
He's over there.
He joked you.
He's going down the stairs.
And shoot him?
He's running in the open.
Shoot him!
He's so far.
He's rev jumping.
Fucking Revenant players.
Disgusting.
Where's our zipline?
I don't know.
We have an Octane.
Oh, he's leaving.
Last time I checked, Octanes don't do...
Someone just landed on us.
Roof!
Fight the guy on the roof!
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
Oh, why did you literally...
Why does his shield go left?
What are you yapping about?
I was using his shield.
They're coming.
Oh, don't worry.
He doesn't know what to do.
Don't rest.
What are you doing?
He doesn't know.
He's literally won.
You're welcome.
I was your bait.
Wow.
You just pushed me off.
That's so fun.
That was hilarious.
You just got dropped.
Wow.
I'm going to remember this.
I'm going to fucking remember this.
I hope you don't get to play Newcastle.
Restia!
He's getting at me!
Don't let him do this!
No!
Restia!
Don't let him do this.
Don't you dare do that!
I'll never do this again.
Oh, yeah.
This is what you guys get.
That's right.
That's fucking karma.
Karma!
I can't believe it, Rusty.
After everything we've been through.
After everything...
I've been on your side this entire time.
I'm gonna remember this.
I'm sorry.
I gotta do this.
Don't fall for her pity baiting, dude.
Don't say you're sorry.
She'll think she won, dude.
Because I did win.
What do you mean?
You're gonna smoke.
There you go.
Now we're safe, guys.
Now we're safe.
Nice.
53 purple.
70 on one.
I got scanned so they know I'm here.
Where did he scan from?
Below right side?
No, like... Oh, he's cracked.
Nice, we got him.
You want me?
I have the bat.
I'm so big.
There's one on you now.
Cracked that guy.
Dead.
No, I have gold lock.
What?
He doesn't care.
He doesn't even care.
Look at him.
I cared.
We're even now.
You just raised him.
I did.
I did raise him.
Yeah, and then I was like, oh, you have...
And then I just found out you had gold knock.
So then I was like, oh, yeah, I should...
I should let you...
Maybe we should take the...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I don't think that's okay.
I'm gonna ult.
Oh, my God.
RPR, RPR.
We're so... RPR, we really need your help.
Um...
Yeah, I'm very healthy.
RPR, why did you do that?
We could literally...
I don't know.
Why did you, like, run away?
What do you mean?
There was three people and you left us.
Like, what do you want me...
Do you think there was anywhere I could have went or what?
You could have just ran downstairs.
You think I had the time for that?
Yeah.
We could craft you.
Clearly, you haven't seen what I saw.
Maybe they'll leave.
Can you go craft us right next to the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, do I have it?
But it's zone four.
It's zone three.
It's fine.
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
It's right behind respawn beacon.
Oh, okay.
Where is it?
You have to craft, go back, heal, then rest.
Um, I think I'm gonna die in zone.
Use your snogs.
What do you mean, use snogs?
Use my fucking... I'm gonna die in zone.
Wait.
Wait!
I deadslide.
I fucking deadslide.
I blame...
I blame RPR for that.
You know your smoke heals you, right?
No, I didn't take it.
I didn't take the smoke.
Why would you not take the healing smoke?
Why would I take the healing smoke?
Because there's no point in taking the other one.
Yes, there is!
When I was playing...
Every time I play in tournament settings, matches, I always ask the IGL, what should I get?
And they always say, get that other one.
And then, yes, yes.
I did so many tournaments with pro players and I always be like, what do I get?
I always ask them.
So I said, they don't do the smoke with heals.
Wait, wait, wait.
No one ever gets the other one.
The other one.
Please tell me you told you that.
Oh, the other IGLs!
I don't remember.
Let me look at my VOD.
I'll be like, what do I get, guys?
Your Rhys told me to get that.
I remember, your Rhys told me.
Your Rhys dropped...
Your Rhys is braindead then.
Dropped is also braindead.
They told you that.
This is just the fact.
The regen is really good.
Why would they tell me to get the other one?
They're baiting you.
I don't know.
Maybe they don't play Bangalore.
Or they don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
I don't know.
They lied to you, maybe.
Even dropped.
Yeah, I mean, maybe he did.
Clearly told you to take the wrong perk.
Damn.
I have never seen a Bang player in pro play not take the regen in smoke.
I mean, that's what they told me to get.
They told me to get the other one.
So I just followed what they said.
Soldiers listen to orders.
They're bad orders.
No gun, no gun.
I wasn't gonna question them.
They are literally the pro player.
You should have questioned it.
You shouldn't just follow people blindly.
Yes, I should.
We are sandwiched between two teams.
It's not good.
Yeah, we are.
I guess Shock surprised me.
Where's the other player?
Hey, I led him to you.
Okay, yeah.
Alright, so you didn't say anything about that other player.
That you were running from.
Yeah, but you never said which side.
I just followed you.
Yeah, I'm trying to help.
I'm struggling.
Guys, I hope you guys die.
So we can re-heal.
Why the fuck would you even say that?
That fucking team player.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna lead a team to you guys.
Why did that guy chase us all the way here?
Oh, there's gonna be another chaser soon.
Oh, never mind.
They're too busy fighting.
They're busy dying.
Yeah.
They just died.
Yeah, I'm safe.
Are you?
Yeah.
They're not even looking outside.
You're Newcastle.
You're always safe.
I have to run to you.
Take some time.
Yeah, and you have a shield.
Oh, and now you're gonna make sure we get shot in the back.
No, I'm looking where we can go up.
Oh my gosh.
Alright, then what do you get?
Do you get tactical cooldown or ultimate cooldown?
You get smoke cooldown.
Yeah, tactical.
Yeah, okay, and then you get smoke.
You get regenerate HP.
Because as Bangler, all you wanna do is you wanna play inside your smokes all the fucking time.
Because now you just get wallhack when you're in smoke.
Okay, maybe it's because the meta changed.
The old meta was like, the left side was better.
In the old meta.
It was always like that.
No, it wasn't.
I remember.
I did so many of those Twitch Rivals and...
Oh yeah!
Mack!
UpperLaylee also told me to get that, too.
I don't know what's Mack smoking, dude.
Literally, when I was on team with Mack, he told me to get the left side, too.
Where am I getting shot at?
Oh!
Right here, behind us!
Okay.
Well, there's another team behind us.
Guys, there's a full team right behind us, by the way.
Is there armor swaps that I need?
I don't have shields.
Okay.
There's a full team right behind.
Where?
It was a horizon.
It was like this direction.
Probably one.
I don't know.
I just know there's a horizon that shot me from that direction.
Someone said, Mack has the VTuber brain.
Wait, your guy debuted to one time?
He fucking gets a VTuber model and instantly plug in as a VTuber.
This is before he got the model!
No, he had the model for a while.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, okay.
Wait, then how does that explain to all the other pro players that fucked me over?
I can't imagine, like, dropping Doki.
Yeah, I don't really I don't know what the fuck happened.
Why did so many pro players fuck me over there?
Literally every time I put it on a Bangalore, I'd be like I would literally ask each pro what do I get for my skill tree?
Every time!
How long ago was this?
This was like for the past six months.
Hashtag Doki.
Maybe it was like...
Can I get a look at my VODs?
Maybe it was a different update before they changed the perks or something, I don't know.
No, no, I remember.
The region was there.
They tell you to pick the left one and you're like, oh, left one, it should be right.
No, and I would read it out.
I'd be like oh, you mean like the the cover me?
The cover me one?
I don't even remember what's the other one.
What's the other one?
The one that pings the people from the smoke thing.
So it gives you intel.
I don't know, I just know healing your smoke is better because you often, as Bangalore, you fight inside smoke and then you get cracked and then you just full heal.
Yeah, you full, you like half heal out of a bad.
Oh, I see.
Oh wait, there's a team behind us because that's an Ashe.
Let's kill them.
Alright.
What do I keep?
I wanna do triple take right now.
I feel like triple taking.
I'm gonna go throw.
I mean, I've been throwing this entire day, but like...
I don't know, maybe there was a patch in which heal was weak, but as far as I can remember, heal was always strong as fuck.
Yeah, that's true.
They're landing on her.
Wait, there's one close.
What the fuck?
See one.
Cracked.
He's right below us here.
Alright, go for it.
He's hiding.
You got this.
I got him.
You're welcome.
Wait, what?
That's...
Okay, there's a Pathfinder next to us.
There's a whole team.
Why me?
We're running.
Why?
It doesn't matter.
I cracked the Horizon.
Zero said the ping was nerfed and the heal was buffed.
I still lagged in RoT.
Yo, I right
now dying in Miraculous and in this situation.
A lot of health.
Oh, well you should...
Oh.
Wait, what?
What was that double knock sound?
They're coming, they're coming, they're coming.
I believe.
Oh, there's no audio on that guy.
Oh, 102!
Pop it in one, pop it in one!
Last guy, last guy!
Yeah!
See?
I need another, I need another fucking heat shield now.
I don't have one.
Heat shield, heat shield.
Well, wouldn't it be funny if you also die in zone?
Nah, I have zone one open.
Hey guys.
Did you still...
Yeah, but that was a long time ago, I'm pretty sure.
Was it really?
When was it?
It was probably like six months ago or something.
There's no way it was six months ago.
There's no way.
I mean...
Oh my god, someone else on you.
Are you good?
I don't think so.
Probably not.
You might need to craft him.
You might...
Yeah, you might need to craft him.
Just leave.
Is that a whole new team?
Yeah.
It was like the duo from like just now.
Oh, it's a duo.
I could have killed him.
No.
I don't think so.
Now we'll never know.
Give me that.
I don't know, but the heal...
The Bangalore heal has been meta for a while now.
They said...
People in my chat said it got nerfed buffed in March.
But like I had...
I had to play Bangalore.
After March.
That's fucking six months ago.
Literally.
Yeah, but I had to play Bangalore after March.
And I still got told to put that.
And every time I would ask.
I would ask every time.
Your teammates were uneducated.
I don't know what to tell you.
One of them is...
One of them is your teammate.
Why aren't you educating your teammate?
He's not...
Yeah.
He's not what?
He plays Newcastle.
You put your Reese on Newcastle?
Yeah.
He's not...
He plays Newcastle.
I got Ricky...
I got Ricky on...
Ricky on fucking Pathfinder because he's most mechanically skilled.
Yeah.
But...
You Reese on Newcastle.
And...
Because I can't IGL on Newcastle.
And I'm on Bang.
Wait.
Why can't you IGL on Newcastle?
Because if you have to rez and throw a shield and I'll do all this shit, you don't have time to focus and tell people what to do while you're fucking doing all the fucking...
Aren't there other IGLs on Newcastle?
Yeah.
Are there other IGLs on Bang?
None of them?
Oh.
You're sending us to die.
Our peer is dead.
I don't...
Rusty, I don't...
I don't think we should...
I got the rez though.
Where do we go, Rusty?
Rusty!
Rusty, where do we go?
We just killed the team.
You guys win those?
Just win.
You guys win those.
Yeah.
Just kill them.
We got one?
I got one.
Okay.
I have a fucking triple tick!
I forgot!
I forgot I had triple tick.
I got killed in Mozambique though.
I got...
I forgot I had a fucking triple tick when I dropped down.
It's okay.
We griefed this team.
They actually died because of this.
Yeah.
Because...
That's why they deserve it.
No, they could like literally...
They could literally...
Wait.
I think they're gonna...
Yeah.
They're gonna craft them.
That's so stupid.
Why don't they commit?
That's what they get for fucking...
Yeah.
...jumping on me while I'm rezzing the...
Oh, and they get finisher.
They deserve that.
They fucking deserve that.
I like that they added this new volume bar while you're spectating.
Holy shit.
Oh, yeah.
It's life-saving.
Makes it...
Oh, what is he...
Why is he shooting?
He could literally craft them.
I don't know.
Not Team Lair.
He could literally use that crafter.
He literally could just...
There's a crafter right next to him.
Oh, no.
He doesn't have to craft them.
He fucking has his beacon.
Yeah.
He has the banner, Doki.
Oh.
No, he could literally craft his teammates right there.
They have like Loba and Lifeline.
That's two crafters.
And this guy is beaming with a 301.
He did 40 damage.
Oh, my God.
He's an MNK player.
That's so rare.
No, that's not him.
No, he's controller.
Wait.
Are you saying he's lying?
No, no.
I'm talking about this fucking...
Who are you watching?
I'm watching this Ashe.
I'm looking at MNK, Sakura, Bloom.
Oh, no.
I'm watching a different guy.
Oh, wait.
There's a different guy that killed you?
Yeah.
This Ashe.
Oh, yeah.
I'm watching an MNK player.
Guys, we can win in plat, right?
Yeah, definitely.
Yes.
Yes, we can.
I believe in us.
All the time.
I win in plat all the time, personally.
Yeah.
Me too.
Personally, I do.
Yeah.
What about you, Ristia?
I'm a plat player.
I never win in plat.
Wait.
How did you get to plat?
Why are you in plat?
I was not playing.
How did you get there?
No, you have to get there.
Why did you stop playing Inter, Ristia?
What happened?
No, I was busy.
I just like came back from US.
Oh, yeah.
You went to...
You went to Google.
I saw it.
Yeah.
He went to the Google headquarters because he's important.
Because I'm a YouTuber, so I'm like a Google employee.
I got like an engineer from a chat, like from Google, and he's just like a little man.
That's so cool.
Showed me like the Google in Seattle.
Yeah.
Do I have engineers in my chat, guys?
I did.
So you got to go to the Google offices because like one of your...
Yeah.
It was super cool.
One of your chatters was like an employee, like one of your fans was an employee at Google.
Yeah.
And the funny part was like after you know the chat, like Google employee, like he knows all the people like in Seattle.
So we actually went to like Amazon.
It was like a sphere thing.
What?
It was like super cool.
You went to Amazon too?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
That's cool.
Did you steal a package?
You saw the warehouse?
Yeah.
I saw the warehouse.
Oh, my God.
You saw the actual Amazon warehouse?
Yeah.
I was like...
I cracked one of them.
You should have stolen a package.
Two balls.
Yeah.
That's two balls.
Oh.
Did you see the bottles?
Wait.
Did you actually like...
You could actually IRL stream from there?
Yeah.
You can.
There's people who are left.
Like not inside...
Like there was like a huge like plant house, like warehouse.
Like there's so much like...
How to say?
Like plants inside.
Like 30K plants.
Yeah.
And people actually work there.
You can like check out my Twitter.
You'll know what it is.
There's like a whole team behind us, guys.
That's like looking at us.
We're like...
Oh, shit.
It's Newcastle on the left.
Yeah.
I cracked two.
Sick nade, bro.
All right.
It's that Newcastle, I believe.
I'm watching.
All right.
I'm one.
I'm pushing this guy.
Whoa.
I'm getting shot.
Yeah.
I mean, we're getting traded.
Newcastle dead.
Nice.
We're the better Newcastle.
That's crazy.
Garcia is literally one HP.
Oakland dead.
It's okay.
We got a pro player here.
Yeah.
That's true.
If he can't 1v2, then like...
They're running.
What's the point?
What's the point of having a pro player?
I'm sending...
I'm not a pro player.
You literally said you're more pro than Restia.
Yeah.
But it doesn't make me a pro player.
I'm sending...
You got this, Restia.
I believe in you.
Your team is already on us.
Okay.
We might need your help, Restia.
Yeah.
Wait.
Where are...
Where are they?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
They're turning rockets on me.
On the roof over here.
Below the roof.
One's to the left, Doki.
One's to the left.
I cracked one of them.
Where's the two on the left?
One's on your left.
Oh, I see him.
Like, super left.
He's right over there behind this box.
They're getting close.
They're not getting close.
You're such a...
Wait.
There's this guy right over there.
He's so far away from us.
Why is he lomboing me from Narnia?
Yeah.
This guy is so far.
He's not getting close.
Watch my back.
What is that in the house?
Yeah, well, three.
All right.
We're fine.
I believe.
Newcastle right here on me.
I'm behind you.
Bang one.
Right here.
Where?
Newcastle dead.
Valve on me.
Oh, nice.
One is dead.
That guy was in the smoke there.
Yeah.
I heard him.
Did he run?
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
Behind us.
That's another...
Is that another one?
Is that another Valk?
Yeah.
But if it's a Valk, it's a different team.
That's a different Valk.
Oh, my God.
I missed every shot.
I cracked him.
I'm batting.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I'm so bad.
It's okay.
You're not pro.
So, like, you can't...
This is bugged out.
I'm going to grab this for heals later.
Where are they?
Are they close to you?
I got one.
Oh, my God.
Dead Valk.
I'm batting.
I thirsted the first guy.
Wait.
The next guy is on me.
The last guy is on the bridge.
Yeah.
I'm resing.
I have the heal.
His teammate is, like, close to us anyway, so they can't res him.
I...
Yeah.
I killed him.
That's right.
No teammate for you.
Is he okay?
I'm not looking.
I'm going to dart to this guy that...
Oh, my God.
How many times are you going to die?
I did not...
It's okay.
I'm not looking.
I just say RP and I did not help you.
I'm sorry.
No.
He had Hammerpoint Mozambique.
This was not...
Oh, yeah.
That was not...
Yeah.
We had to use...
He has bait.
Sorry.
You were chosen to debate.
I'm massive as fuck and he has Hammerpoint Mozambique.
Yeah.
Like...
He had double...
Was it double Mozambique or one Mozambique?
Double Mozambique and Hammerpoint GG.
What the fuck?
How did he get so lucky?
There's a...
Oh, there's a gold backpack.
This game is biased as fuck.
I love Apex.
Okay.
Why do you want to say that?
If you don't play it regularly, you start loving it again.
I love Apex as well.
Yeah?
I mean, I haven't played Apex properly in like two years.
They just res...
Where?
Here.
Oh.
I have it so like when I go to the bar, I can just use my license.
And be like, look, see, I can buy drinks.
Where did he go?
It's just one guy.
He's just juking.
Where's his teammates?
I don't know.
Well, this guy's running Scout and Spitfire.
What a fucking gamer.
What is he playing?
Oh, there's Valka and Rocket.
Oh, what the fuck?
How did they do that?
Oh, I see his teammates right here.
I don't know, but they're gifting us free kills.
What the?
Ok.
Oh, wait, I can do this.
I can smoke here.
Look.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm just trying to my best.
I'm trying to my best just to get my team.
I'm healing so much in smoke now.
Oh, now I know what... now I get it.
They actually did buff this.
I can't hit those.
Should I have one to two?
Where are they fighting?
Like at the pyramid.
Are they still?
We're not going there.
Yeah, we're not going there.
I don't want to be in zone, dude.
They're still literally fighting right there.
This guy said license.
Literally just do drink and drive.
Yeah, great advice, dumbass.
What?
Yay!
Sometimes I wonder how people in my chat survive on a daily basis.
What are you trying to say about your chat?
Are you trying to say your chat's dumb?
Yeah.
Whoa!
Hey, my chat and Besty's chat, you're not dumb.
Not all of them, but like when you put them together, they're up there, dude.
They're up there as dumbasses.
So you're trying to say the average IQ of your chat is below average.
No, it's just like when they band together, they're dumb.
They're rezzing.
Send it!
Bro, they're like fucking...
They got it all?
When you put them all together into one cohesive unit, it's fucking bad, dude.
Are we really just waiting for them here?
Yeah, I mean, do you want to go inside the orange shit?
Oh, no!
How is there no bats on this map?
Oh, somebody dyed a ring.
How?
I'm just going to go loot this because I need bats.
Yeah, but like, they gotta come over here, right?
Oh, they could go to the other side.
You guys do not reflect the streamer.
Oh, true!
Chat reflects the streamer!
That's so true!
Oh, so you say your chat reflects you?
No, are you chat... Yeah, that's why I'm saying my chat's smart.
Yeah, our chat is smart.
Yeah, our chat's smart.
Your chat is dumb.
If you say chat does not reflect the streamer, how would you explain Imperial Hal's chat?
What?
What about his chat?
Yeah, I'm just saying his chat is very much like the...
I'm trying to say his chat is very much like the streamer.
That's all I'm saying.
What are you trying to imply?
What are you trying to say about his chat?
I'm just trying to say his chat is very much like his personality and the chat's personality are very similar.
I don't know.
I don't watch Hal that much anymore.
I wonder just how does his chat act?
What is it that they do?
They're gamers.
Because Hal's a gamer.
Can you be a little bit more specific?
Hal's a gamer and they're gamers.
Yeah, what are you trying to imply?
That's what you meant the entire time.
I was just wondering.
They're just as smart as him.
I haven't managed to watch Hal in a while, so I was just wondering.
I don't hear anything.
You seem to know so much about his chat.
Yeah, because I'm just saying that they're pretty smart.
Oh my god.
We lost one.
I cracked him.
He's so low though.
I'm batting.
I got balled, bro.
I got balled too.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm getting hit by everything.
Like what?
Oh my god.
He's cracked.
Shoot this guy behind.
Oh my god.
What the fuck happened?
What?
I don't know.
Our Oak team died.
Oh it's over.
I don't think it was your fault.
I think it's our idea for not telling us that there was a team there.
He takes audio.
What the fuck?
But he has double Mozamm?
That's not fair!
I only had one Mozamm!
He had double Mozamm?
He only did 56 shots?
Like 56 damage?
That's fucking crazy.
What happened?
You know, everyone has...
Everyone has, like, one death, you know?
One freebie.
I don't die, dude.
You died... you died second.
Responsibility of, like, dying first, dying second.
All I'm saying is that... Based on RPR's logic, like, Doki, you have the lowest ping, so you should carry.
That is not true.
That is true.
That is a good point, Rustia.
No, no, no, no.
Good job.
Because I have the least experience out of all three of us when it comes to Apex.
So, by that logic, the person with the most experience competitively and in rank should be the one that carries us, because to them, ping doesn't matter that much when you're against plat players.
Yeah, I saw that.
I didn't hear a single word you said.
I didn't hear anything.
Okay, that's nice.
What happened?
Also, wasn't it in some of the games?
Like, Rustia and I got the most damage.
You know the point, like, Apex, you just shut up when you have, like...
You just, like, don't talk about it when you have the least damage.
Wait, no, Rusty, you had the least damage!
Wait, you're right, Rusty!
Not that you mentioned it!
Rusty, you had the least damage out of all of us!
And you're higher ranked than me right now!
Alright, I'll take responsibility of that.
Is that why Rusty is so quiet lately?
After every game ending?
Oh, it was a holy damn match!
I can't believe it, the self-report from Rusty.
The fucking self-report from Rusty.
You know what I tend to notice about it when I play with my Pred teammates before?
Every time I die first, I'm like, I'm sorry boys, it's my fault.
And then I see when they're dying first, they're like, Oh, we don't talk about it.
We don't talk about it.
Those people.
I have a P20, so I hope we'll be okay.
Standing over.
He's one.
Got him for you.
This last guy here, or not last guy, but one of the guys here is literally 1 HP.
Okay.
He's shooting my knockdown.
You'll be fine.
Fucking brain to the fuck.
I had to...
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
He's right here, by the way, on this door.
Oh, you...
Wait, I'm getting shot from behind.
Oh my god, I fucking barrel stuffed that guy.
Did you grab his banner?
Yeah.
Alright, that's good.
That's not on me.
Oh, last guy is resing.
Where did he go?
He just low button left him.
I'm gonna res RPR.
See, look at that.
I'm a team player.
Yeah, great team player.
Literally, I'm going to res you.
Doing so much teamwork.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Sloppy.
Upgrades locked and loaded.
See?
Look at that.
There we go.
I did it.
Good team play, Doki.
Yeah.
See?
Unlike some people, I don't hold grudges.
Yeah.
It's like I never res you ever.
I never res you in my life.
Yeah, because there's always Restia.
Because Restia knows how to play for the team.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
Wait, where's Restia?
Where are they?
Inside?
Two teams?
Three teams?
What the fuck?
I don't have this fucking lag.
Wait, over here?
Wait, he's climbing up.
He's climbing up.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
I just saw a rev fucking ran.
Oh, wait.
They're resing in front of you?
He's cracked?
What is he doing?
He's literally one.
He's literally one outside my door.
Right here.
He just shoot him outside.
Okay.
That guy was stupid.
Toxic.
That's toxic.
He literally got off the door to throw his fucking mini shield.
I don't know what the fuck that guy was trying to do.
What would your chat say when you're toxic like this?
They're like, wow, Doki.
You go, girl.
Girl power.
Girl boss.
You can't just fucking eat quick.
Yeah.
Girl power.
Wow.
What a girl boss.
Right there.
Let's go.
Wow.
Very non-toxic.
Thank you, chat.
I agree.
She's just making up messages.
I'm literally looking at my chat right now.
Where's his teammate?
Oh, right there.
Hey, look.
He's too busy looting to res you.
Well, you know.
He's just...
First thing you do before you res is armor swap.
If you believed in your teammates, you wouldn't need armor swap.
Res was braindead shit you said to me.
You would believe in me to cover you while you res him.
So you could leave the...
Why would I put myself at a disadvantage on purpose when I can spend one second looting Because all the teams are dead.
See, I would res you about armor swapping because I am a team player.
There won't be.
Yeah.
So you would do a braindead move.
Good job.
If that doesn't make you smart, it makes you stupid.
It makes me a team player that believes in my team with the power of friendship.
No, it makes you a team player that is sabotaging her own team by not being full health.
A team with the most friendship and belief tends to win land.
That's not true.
That's true.
The last one...
You gotta say that's not true.
The last land chap literally got kicked out after winning land.
That's so fucked.
Holy shit.
They won land and got kicked out.
That's actually so fucked.
Didn't he fucking do something to deserve that or some shit?
I don't know.
I just know that...
I don't know what he did.
What did he do?
I just saw that like...
I don't know.
He was like being toxic and shit apparently.
I mean, isn't that like Apex players in general?
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, but some people can handle toxicity and others can't.
Oh, I see.
That's fucked though still.
I feel like, you know, he should be in the...
I think it's stupid to be toxic to your teammates because you're equal.
Like you instantly make an environment in which your teammate doesn't want to team with you anymore.
Yeah.
To the point that you get kicked out after winning.
You're making a team for like what?
One land?
And then you're definitely making a roster swap because everyone hates you now because you're toxic to them.
Yeah.
One of like...
I like how you did with like, you know, like Manne and Ty'shin.
Like you...
It just went well and then you don't, don't talk about it.
Just like, okay, we'll play next time.
Oh...
Okay, don't worry.
I'm gonna- Especially during like LAN.
Why would you argue?
Wait, were they arguing in LAN too?
Yeah, they were arguing all the time.
Their NA.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, I got this guy.
Yeah.
More from behind.
Don't let them rez, that was my kill.
Yeah, that was the worst.
The worst thing pro players do is the passive-aggressive shit.
Oh yeah, I hate that shit.
Yeah, you're right.
NA players do that shit all the fucking time.
It's so annoying.
It's so childish as well.
Yeah, just say it to their face.
Don't need to do the...
It's like, dude, do you have something to say?
Just fucking say it, bro.
Like, what are you doing?
I cracked one.
I was reloading second kill.
I'm ulting.
And I want... yeah, it's a new team.
Just two more.
They all went back.
Yeah.
Oh, they all went back?
In the portal?
All went back to the portal, yeah.
Oh, okay.
So my ult is...
Thank you for ulting.
No worries, guys.
No worries.
Just for you guys.
I don't think they're coming back.
I think that's my biggest pet peeve with like...
pro players that...
They're such children sometimes.
It's so annoying.
A lot of pro players are incredibly young.
And they're actually like...
They're young, though.
Yeah, they're young.
Yeah.
But like...
I don't give a fuck how young you are.
Why are you being passive aggressive to your teammates?
Like, if there's an issue...
Because they treat it like it's high school.
You can just fucking speak about it.
If you just speak about it, we can solve the issue.
If you're just fucking being a little bitch, we can't fucking solve shit, man.
It's because like a lot of like...
Especially pro players, they started out like super young becoming pro.
And because of that, they like treat it like it's high school.
And it's like an ego thing, too.
I don't know, but it's annoying.
And a lot of teams that should be teams literally disband because they're children.
You think they'll kill me from this zip?
Guys, I think...
No.
Guys.
Guys, I'm...
But they'll kill you at the end of the zip.
Yeah, so I'm fucking dropping off now.
Kill the revenant.
Whoa.
The shield's broken.
He's one.
He's literally one.
I can't touch him.
All right.
I'm going up.
He's jumping somewhere.
I believe.
Oh, he got the zip.
He's using his Pathfinder zip.
I can't kill him.
He's fucking...
I can't even see him.
He's like a little speck on my screen.
We could kill this.
Yeah, let's do it.
Famous last words.
What, behind me?
Oh, whoa, whoa.
We need to save Restia.
Oh, my God.
Are they...
Oh, they're...
Yeah, full team, full team, full team.
Yeah, wait.
Just let him die.
Let him die.
Well, I'm going to die too.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm...
Just run if you can.
I'm running.
But he has hammer point.
I felt the hammers.
Okay.
Oh, well, thank you for the speed boost.
Whoa.
Hey, guys.
Oh, goodbye.
Res him.
It'll be so funny.
They're on us.
What the fuck?
No one here at all.
I'm dead.
Oh, no.
That's how I died.
No audio on this guy.
That's literally how it happened.
You should know about like the new season, right?
Like the characters with cyber legs, like Pathfinder, Octane, or like Rift.
Wait, really?
That's fucked.
That's been happening for months now.
So it's just like...
Well, I can craft you here.
What's new?
Yeah.
Well, you have his banner.
You just have to craft it.
Yeah.
But I have to craft you too.
That's fine.
Whoa.
Wait, do I not have...
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, wait.
No, I do.
I was going to say, do I not have it?
There's no way I get shot here, right?
No, I don't see...
Oh, they're over there.
They're literally over there watching it.
Like to fucking zoom out a little bit and just...
This is going to be zone three.
So you can...
And it's not going to touch the respawn beacon.
You're going to be able to see.
Never mind.
Okay.
They saw me, guys.
How did they see me?
I don't understand.
I was...
Bro, why the fuck are you trying to hammer point?
Do you know that in the latest patch, they made a patch note saying that they fixed audio?
Oh, yeah.
I remember.
Yeah.
They especially fixed the audio around footsteps specifically.
That's what they said.
What the fuck?
How they...
Why are they still chasing me?
Fucking free.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Where's the other team?
Yeah.
Well, anyway, that was a fucking lie.
Where the fuck is the other team?
There we go.
I don't know, but...
Fucking run.
I'm trying to.
All right.
Nice.
Do you think they're...
If they're going to still chase you, just go towards the other team so they end up dying for chasing you.
Yeah.
They are.
They're dying.
They're literally dying for it.
They're literally...
Okay.
Now go res us to the left.
Yeah.
They literally are dying because of it.
Holy fuck.
That was cringe.
Let's go.
It's so funny that they wrote...
They fixed audio specifically footsteps.
That's not good.
And then half the characters have no abilities.
What?
Okay.
I'm dead.
Oh, my God.
I got killed by pure Halo.
What the fuck?
They saw me from there?
F-O-C-N Imperial Halo.
Yeah.
Without Imperial Halo.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I got killed by Imperial Halo.
The motherfucking goat.
Holy shit.
He's gaming.
I can't believe...
At least the team that chased us died.
I hope.
I think.
They just...
They look like they died.
I don't know.
I like when teams do that in ranked.
They never learn.
They just chase us all and die because of it.
Yeah.
Because they got greedy.
They're just like, this one KP in my plat game.
Yippee.
Guys.
I think...
I believe in us in winning one plat game.
That should be our goal.
That is...
I mean, we were close.
Like, what?
We were close.
I believe in us.
It can't be that difficult.
We can...
As long as Resti doesn't die, we're good.
That's true.
I mean, if we die...
We die twice because of it.
Maybe...
You just need to be pathfinder.
Oh, you're...
If you're pathfinder, then you can be the person that sneaks up onto others.
Oh, I'm playing serious this game.
I don't know how to play serious.
Oh, you weren't playing serious?
Serious in the plot?
No, I wasn't.
This guy never plays serious.
He doesn't play serious in bronze.
He doesn't play serious in soul.
He doesn't play serious in the plot.
Where are you going to play serious then?
When will you start being serious?
It's just excuse Andy, bro.
Wow.
That's not true.
Prove me wrong then.
Yeah, prove him wrong by being serious now.
If you're not top fragger, Restia, then you're not serious.
Alright, I'm serious.
Serious mode, let's go.
Oh, he's serious now, guys.
He's going to be top fragger.
Let's see what serious Restia can do.
Yeah, yeah, let's see, yeah, yeah.
Are you guys scanning the zone in front of me?
This caustic is a joke.
I can't see him.
Oh, he's dead.
He tried to scan zone.
What the fuck?
He's literally...
This guy's...
Crypto right here, also a questionable moment.
I have to cock the gun again.
Why did you bring this Crypto?
Because I don't know.
He's so serious.
I just got three Norex on him.
Oh my god, Restia's so serious.
Look at this.
Yep, was so serious.
Did you hear that?
Why did that caustic go for fucking zone scan?
Right in front of him.
He wanted the charge, the ult charge.
He's so serious that he's controller looting too.
Wait, are you a controller?
Yeah.
I know, I saw it.
Stan's still looting.
Don't tell me you switched to controller.
No, no, no, I don't.
I hate controller.
Okay.
You get minus one friendship if you switched.
Yeah, that's how Serious plugs in the controller.
I think they're fighting here, man.
Yeah, they're heading over.
Like right here.
All right.
I'm heading over.
They're fighting here now.
Oh, I'm grabbing some.
We should first clean up our POI, Restia, before we go to other POIs.
Look, he's serious.
He's got 1v3.
He's serious.
He can 1v3.
They'll kill these guys.
All right.
I'm heading over.
I'm here to help you, RPRC.
I'm a team.
They're in this building.
Or they were in this building, at least.
Where are they now?
It's a Watson.
Oh, I see him.
They're running right side.
Are you okay over there, Restia?
Yeah.
He's serious.
He's okay.
Okay.
They're running up the hill.
Oh, he wants you in the building.
He wants you in the building.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Is he still?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
The other guy is probably a resin teammate because there's...
Yeah.
No, they are.
They smoked it.
Wait.
Oh, I thought you were going to...
I thought you were flanking the rest.
Yeah.
But don't worry.
We got this.
Oh.
Where is he running to?
Whoa.
He's tap strafing.
That's a rampart.
On top.
Whoa.
Look.
Do a finisher.
Where's the last guy?
Do a finisher?
Yeah.
Okay.
He ran that way.
He was tap strafing that way.
Yeah.
He was tap strafing.
He was.
I was literally watching him dodge my bullets and tap strafing.
I was like, whoa.
Where's the other team?
Which character was it?
It was a Bangalore.
Bangalore.
Where could they be?
Where the fuck did he go?
Oh, team here.
Team here.
Let's kill them.
In front of me.
Whoa.
He tried to snipe me in the air.
What a gamer.
I only see one guy.
Where do you see team?
One's on the roof.
Wait.
He's one.
On the roof.
On HP.
Okay.
Goodbye, guys.
Goodbye.
I got 2v1.
Which one is one?
The seer.
The seer that's on me.
He's got armor swap.
There's two here.
Inside.
They have a lifeline as well.
So he's going to be full healed.
I can't believe it.
It's okay.
Someone's landing on us.
Restia, new team.
Okay.
Restia.
I killed one team.
I killed one from new team.
There's no Audio Newcastle on me then.
Where is his metal legs?
What the .
But I thought they fixed.
Go to the juicer.
Go there.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing it.
I thought the, these guys said they fixed the audio.
What happened?
They lied.
Epex Legend's lying to us?
There's no way.
I'm always an apex believer.
Jeez.
Yes.
How bad do you want that sponsorship?
I already got sponsored, what do you mean?
So you can drop the act then.
What do you mean?
I want to keep getting sponsored.
I don't know about you guys, but I get paid to play this game.
I mean, unless she was getting paid for like five years to play the game.
Just not from them.
Well, from them too, because they kept winning their journeys.
Oh, look at that.
I always believed in Restia.
I'm a team player, by the way.
Yeah, I knew it.
That technically makes you the pro player since you're making money off this game.
So you should be carrying us though.
No, because you've made the most out of tournaments though.
Yeah, but I'm not a pro player anymore.
You are currently a pro player.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, that doesn't count.
No, no, no, that's exactly how it works.
It doesn't count.
No, no, no, I'm getting paid as a content creator.
No, no, no, no.
If you're making money off the game, you're a pro player.
There's a team that's on Restia right now.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is going on?
Did we take the zip?
I think we took the zip.
I missed the zip.
I got him.
I believe in the professional ex-player.
I'm not a pro player.
Then what are you?
There's another team.
Just pretend you're already dead.
Oh, he saw you.
You're sort of fucked.
I'm going to watch this.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, they're coming into the hall.
They're coming into the hall.
Oh, they're definitely in there.
Oh, yeah.
You're still alive?
Oh, shit.
Oh, you're so dead.
You're going to duck on your ass.
Wait, how did you live that?
Don't ask questions you don't want to answer.
I heard the jump pad.
I heard a jump pad.
I got Restia's banner.
I knew you'd survive.
A little grief.
A little bit.
Just a little bit.
I have, like, literally, like, no attachments.
I need my gun.
I mean, yeah, we just got spotted.
I have four cells.
I have nothing.
We can craft here.
You got this.
I have a mobile respawn, though.
Yeah, you just need to craft me.
Or you could, like, res Restia now and then craft me and then res me on the other res.
I feel like if I res first, I'm going to get fucking aggroed on and then we're going to die by the time I craft you.
Yeah, but then Restia would survive.
Yeah, but if I res both of you guys, you have higher chances 3v3.
Well, we lost the last 3v3.
Wait, no, we won it because I carry.
You don't have to fucking point that out, dude.
Yeah, we can let Restia pull aggro.
Hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up.
That's three fucking teams.
Oh, you are using Restia.
What happened?
I thought you weren't going to use Restia's aggro.
What happened is that we were not going to live through it.
Goodbye, Restia.
Goodbye.
Oh, look at him.
He has a shield already and everything.
Come here and res me.
He's not.
He's chasing alone, alone.
He's alone behind you.
I don't think he is.
I don't know.
He is alone.
Oh, it's in time zone.
It's in time zone.
Dumbass.
Let's take Rift's game.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, he's one HP.
He's literally one.
That was so close.
He's dead, though.
This team is going to kill him now.
Wait, how is he going to...
No, he's all right.
There's a team right next to him that's not shooting at him.
What?
Are they teaming?
What is he doing?
No, we'll never know.
We got him.
We'll never know.
It's OK.
We'll probably sleep there.
We'll never know what happened to him.
Damn, I really thought I griefed them, dude.
He probably died to his own.
He was one HP, right?
Probably.
Probably, like, you would assume so.
Okay.
Now that we're all...
They were all getting out of there.
We were surrounded.
Look, I think it's because not all of us were serious.
If all of us start playing seriously, then like we'll win this next game.
Rezzy was serious.
I was serious.
I was serious too.
I was very serious.
So all of us were serious then?
No, no, no.
Someone's lying and it's not me.
No, it's definitely not you.
I literally helped you knock two when we got Rezzed.
What do you mean?
I mean, yeah, why would you lie?
Like that's insane.
Yeah, why would I lie?
I'm always serious when I have to be.
Since you're so serious, you can just jump master us.
Yeah, sure.
Seriously.
There we go.
That's a very serious drop here.
Yeah, it is because I believe in my team to not die.
That's a serious laugh, by the way.
That's a serious statement.
There is a team in this building.
But because I believe...
I believe in my teammates.
There's an Ashe.
There's an Ashe with me.
Flesh?
How did I just end up with a wingman?
What the fuck?
He's like one.
He's literally one.
Is there a sniper on me anywhere?
Nope.
I don't have a wingman.
There's a charge rifle here.
Well, is there a sniper on me?
Uh, yeah.
I'm gonna go for this Ashe.
Oh, he left.
Back down?
Where?
In the house?
I'm heading over to you.
On the roof.
Is he still on the roof?
He's inside the house now?
Holy life.
I'm in the house?
Wait, this guy has a tap strafer again.
On my door.
Flesh?
I'm getting shot in my back as well.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm healing.
I'm healing.
I only have syringe.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's awkward.
Crack the fuck out of him.
Swing that guy.
I have to reload.
I don't have ammo.
If there's him, I really need this.
Break that.
Oh my god.
No audio again.
There's a new team.
I know.
I need a heal.
Just run.
Running is the best option.
Oh, okay.
I didn't realize running...
Oh, are you guys sure running was the best option?
Yeah, I mean, there's two more teams, so running is the best option.
Oh, okay.
Okay, let's do this.
Oh, Crafthouse Resnus?
Sure, let's do it.
I'm not dead yet.
I'm dead now.
Okay, I only have a shield back, but that's fine.
They're fucking killing each other now.
Okay.
Yeah.
They won't know.
Yeah, you can res us right there and we'll win.
That's why I'm trying to...
And that's from Gouda.
Bring them home.
He's right there behind you.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
I have to walk around.
They won't know, right?
I literally have no skills.
Yeah, there's some busy.
They are still 1v1'ing, I think.
Two knocks from one team.
And then one knock from another team.
I am just going to see if there are heals here.
Yeah, there is a bubble as well.
They are probably bubble resin.
By the way, I got killed by no audio again.
I am going to thirst.
Oh, I see them.
They are on the roof.
I am looking at them, but...
I am just going to try and thirst this guy for you guys.
One is on the roof.
And the other enemy team is also there.
There are a couple on the roof.
What the fuck?
Where did he go?
I mean...
Oh.
Splash, splash.
Oh, there is two.
Gibraltar, splash.
How many people are here?
What the fuck?
A lot.
Guys, there is a lot of people.
There is another team on the second floor.
Alright.
There is a new team, I think.
A lifeline which is double Mozambique.
That is a new team.
I see it.
Dude, that is crazy that he could use a fucking gold player.
That just puts me down like that.
Because he is double Mozambique.
Holy shit, how many teams showed up.
That is crazy.
Yeah, I ruined your mom.
The rest brought in the entire two new teams.
This is who killed me, bro.
That is not on us chat.
That was literally like 8th party central.
Right there.
Someone in my chat is asking me, what is a good dog name?
What is a good dog name?
Name your dog after RPR.
So you can...
Why would you name your dog after RPR?
That is hard to say.
Why not RPR?
Hey, RPR.
Come on, RPR.
I think Axel is a great name, personally.
Oh yeah, name it after me.
Don't name it after her.
Name it after me.
Why not?
Okay.
Name the fucking dog, Doki.
Yeah, my dog's name is Doki.
Really?
Yeah, I need my dog after myself.
That is the first...
Why?
Why not?
It is going to be like a situation like, what are you peeing here, Doki?
Something like that.
No, I call him I call him Dad for Doki Amber Doge.
Or I call him Doki Doggo.
Is the person you love the most in your life yourself or what?
No, it's my dog and me.
Yeah, love yourself.
You gotta love yourself.
My mom said, Jesus Christ, the dog has a first and last name.
And a middle name.
Yeah, he's gonna be in my will.
That's not...
Can you put dogs in your will?
Yeah, I think you can.
You can actually.
You can like...
What can you give them?
I don't know, money?
You don't know what a will is?
Like when you die, you will your stuff.
You give your stuff to other people.
So they'll know who gets what.
It's like your last will.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
My dog can like get my money.
He can own my...
I don't fucking know.
Do dog things.
It's his money now.
I don't think you can give dogs money.
Yes, you can.
You can technically.
And then what happens when a dog passes away?
Who gets the money?
I guess like no one.
The bank.
So you leave it to the bank?
I would never leave it to the bank.
Oh, you don't trust your bank?
I just don't trust banks in general.
What do you mean?
Wait, so you keep all your money underneath your bed in gold or some shit?
No, I keep it in the bank.
Yeah, if you keep it in the bank, why are you keeping it in the bank if you don't trust the bank?
You gotta keep it somewhere.
You don't want to keep that much cash in there.
Just convert it into gold bars and keep it under your bed.
Yeah, that's what I'm thinking about.
Converting to gold bars is crazy.
What do you mean?
It's actually good.
Wait, do you actually do that, Rustia?
No, I don't know.
But you said it was good.
Why are you guys giving me advice you wouldn't do yourself?
I mean, to be honest, it is smart to keep your money in gold because gold basically never loses value and money loses value over time.
Now people do it for American dollars because we all know the American dollar will never lose in value.
Oh yeah, surely.
Yeah, surely the bubble won't burst.
Well, I keep my money in euros because euros worth more than the dollar.
Yeah, that's true.
Keep your money in euros.
What if the...
What if the European Union disbands and what will you do?
I feel like if the European Union disbands, we're kind of fucking...
We're just gonna fuck, you know?
It's probably like World War 3 type shit.
Yeah, but then your euros are gonna be worthless.
That's why you gotta keep in gold bars.
Yeah, but you know, if something like that happens, everything kind of becomes useless, Doki.
You don't know that.
Close to apocalyptic situation.
You can use the gold bars as a weapon.
Or...
How?
Use it to whack people.
Yeah, you put it in the...
Gold is a soft metal.
You can't even turn it into a sword, dude.
No, it's really hard.
It's really hard.
What do you mean?
It's a gold bar.
It's a fucking bar.
It's heavy as fuck.
Gold is one of the softest metals.
Who am I talking to?
Yeah, but if you use it to fucking hit somebody, then it's gonna hurt.
You put it in a...
Yeah, you throw it...
Once you throw in your one gold bar, No, you don't throw it.
You put it in a pillowcase.
You put it in a pillowcase, and then you whack people with it.
You wouldn't stay that long in the fucking post-zombie apocalypse.
I can't believe we're talking about how to whack people with gold bars.
I'm just saying, a gold bar is a better weapon than Euros.
No.
What do you mean no?
What you could do instead, take your Euros and equip yourself for a post-apocalyptic situation with a bunch of weapons and shit, so when it does hit, when Euros and gold are useless, you have guns.
Yeah, but you don't know when it's gonna hit.
It comes out of nowhere.
You can't just predict that.
It doesn't matter if you don't know.
That's how you stay prepared.
Are you prepared?
Are you prepared for the doomsday situation?
I'm always prepared.
No, you're not.
You don't know if I'm being prepared.
You still have your Euros.
Who says I'm not using my Euros?
Just because I have them.
There's just one car there.
Where are they?
Why is there a car there in the middle of the road?
He came up to me and shot me.
Then I shot him and he ran away.
He's literally right there.
Liar.
He told me he ran away.
If he's there, then kill him.
Shoot him.
I have the heal.
Why are you losing?
He shot me first.
Excuse me.
Where did he go?
I'm not sure.
He was heading back.
I'm going to lose.
Ducky, do you think if there was a zombie apocalypse or any apocalypse of any kind that you would be able to survive?
Oh no, I'd die.
I 100% would die.
We're literally streamers.
What kind of survival skills do I have?
I'd live.
I know why you're laughing.
You don't know nothing about me.
I mean, I believe you.
Why did you laugh, Rusty, when you said that?
I don't know why you're laughing.
He looks like he looks like he's going to be in the apocalypse.
He looks like he's already living through it.
I would easily survive apocalypse.
I'm the most capable of all the pro players in the fucking Apex.
I'm the most capable of survival.
What do you fucking know about me?
What do you know if I go outside right now?
You don't fucking know this shit.
You're just talking on your ass.
I fucking stream how many times a week?
Five or six.
That leaves me two days, one to two days to do whatever I want.
Nice.
And what do you do?
Workout.
There's a guy here.
Oh, okay.
That's his teammates, right?
That poor guy, leaving his teammates out there to die.
I never do that.
I just noreg them.
And he's crafting his teammates in front of me.
That's what he's looking like.
He doesn't respect you.
Wait, you're right.
If RPR can survive, I can survive.
I live in Canada!
Zombies can't get me in Canada.
It's too cold.
That doesn't stop them.
In movies it does.
If it's too cold, the zombies...
Canada is usually like the safe haven from a zombie apocalypse.
No fucking way.
I've never heard that in my life.
It's in every movie.
There's some bullshit.
People will just freeze.
People will be like, let's move to Canada because there's lack of zombies here.
Explain Project Zomboid then.
Project Zomboid isn't in Canada.
Project Zomboid has winter.
Like really bad winter.
Yeah, but it's not Canadian winter.
You're making no fucking sense.
No, you don't know what Canadian winter is like.
Extra supplies, let's go.
It's true though.
In every zombie scenario...
In every zombie scenario, they'll always be like, let's move to...
I don't know what kind of zombie scenarios you were watching.
They're like, let's move to Canada.
Because it's like the safe...
Even in The Walking Dead, they're like, let's go to Canada.
It's the safest.
Oh my god, what the...
Did the robot legs get you again?
Did the robot...
Did the robot legs...
I think the robot legs got to him.
I'll be able to escape.
I'm gonna go craft him.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Why is he always so far away from us?
He can't help it, the robot legs!
I was killing...
the guy that was in zone.
I was running, dude.
What do you mean?
You're not paying attention, you're dying.
No, I'm paying attention.
You don't understand.
Dad, it's the robot legs!
The audio!
Was it actually the robot legs, Justia?
It is.
To be completely honest, there were two guys on my ass and there was zero audio.
I had no clue.
It's okay, I got you.
Was that backfiring?
You keep dying to audio, dude.
Alright.
I'm going into gear 3, dude.
Going to what?
You know what, Justia?
Justia, what do you need to do?
I'm not gonna die.
I'm not gonna die again.
Okay, I believe in you.
I thought you were serious, by the way.
There's a big fight here!
Justia's not a cat girl, he's an actual cat now.
He's a literal cat.
Justia was never a cat girl.
Yes, he was.
He's a dude.
He was a cat girl.
A dude can be a cat girl.
I caught two of them in there.
I got one.
I'm fucking penis.
Oh my god, he's flashed!
He's flashed!
Last guy outside here.
Alright.
Last guy out here.
He's resing, he's healing.
I'll res, I'll res, I'll res.
That's not you, okay.
I knew it.
Restio got super serious.
Yup.
Oh hey, there's another.
Oh yeah.
You wanna give me that fucking gold knockdown or what?
You didn't have one?
I thought you had one.
Why did you ask me and not Restio?
He had a fucking gold first!
Did I say a name?
I don't care.
What do you want from me?
You are yelling at Restio too!
I said can you give me a gold knockdown.
I didn't say Restia or Doki.
One of you give me a fucking knockdown.
Restia had it first.
Why are you picking one up to begin with, Doki?
I dropped the purple by the way.
He's a purple.
Level three.
I'm a purple.
Gold one.
No, I'm talking about Restia because I think about other people too.
She didn't say a name.
Yeah, I didn't say a name.
Exactly.
I didn't say a name.
Who's won?
This guy with red armor there literally has one HP on base health and almost nothing.
Oh, I see him.
I don't actually.
I think maybe.
I don't.
I didn't see him.
He's hiding here as well.
I knocked one.
What the fuck?
Go, Doki, go.
I'm heading over.
Oh my god.
He slowed me down.
One team dead.
I think there's two knocks.
I just got beam.
On me?
On you?
On me.
Wait, there's a different team then.
It's the teams, yeah.
Okay, I'm backing out then.
It's under you.
Under me?
Oh, yeah.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god, you just threw me into the fucking pit.
I should have streamed.
Yeah, even when you help her, it's not good enough.
What do you mean?
Horizon Q scared the shit out of me.
I didn't say it didn't help.
I just said that you almost threw me into the pit, but I didn't get thrown into the pit.
It's never good enough.
I didn't say that.
Now you're putting words in my mouth.
I'm not gonna say who, but somebody in my chat said you need hearing aid, ducky.
That's not true.
Oh, so you're just gonna get one guide?
No, you're getting one guide.
There's people in front of me.
I'm just reading out a comment that I agree with.
I cracked two.
What the fuck?
Oh, there's a team inside here too.
Oh wait, Rusty is getting a D.Va, so he doesn't care.
I'm not a team player now.
Alright, I'm gonna grab stuff here.
Yeah, but there's four teams alive, so where's the other two?
I don't know, but let's kill someone.
Oh, over there?
I saw a shot there.
Yeah, I saw bullets, yeah.
Oh, they're fighting here or something.
Oh, a Loba ulted.
Guy in the roof got cracked here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm heading over.
I'm walking up.
They're fighting here.
Where's here?
On my ping.
A bunch of dead, a bunch of dead motherfuckers.
Okay, I'm heading to the roof right now.
One team dead.
Where's the other team?
They're just like deep.
Deep on this side.
I'm heading over.
What?
Where are they?
I don't know if they got wiped or not.
I think they got wiped.
Woah, Rusty!
I'm fine.
Who are you shooting at?
Bull dead?
No, there's more, there's more.
I'm looking.
Oh, I see him.
Red armor, too, in front of me.
Pathfinder.
Is this one guy or what?
I don't know, I just saw red armor, pathfinder.
Dude, let's get the roof here.
Alright.
What do I see?
On my door, right here.
At the bottom.
What?
I got one.
Oh my god, he's actually one.
I pulled dead.
Pathfinder's lost.
He's running over.
Oh, where's the last team?
No idea.
Guys, are we gonna win?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, guys!
We're all so serious!
I think he's here, behind this wall.
Let's throw.
Oh yeah, that's...
Flash.
Alright.
Yay!
Oh, he does the lob over the red armor to run away from me.
Oh, that's him.
We did it, guys!
We went serious mode!
It happened!
We won our pilot game, that's crazy.
Oh my god, that means like, Breastia deserves his rank.
Yeah, I said I was a player.
Yeah, yeah.
But if you're winning in Plat, Lobbystar, you're better than Plat players?
Yes, that means you're technically a Diamond player.
Why do you have Team Liquid banner?
Wait, who?
Me?
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh, he wants to support Team Liquid.
Do you like Team Liquid the most?
Oh, I was...
Like, it was before when Noq was on Team Liquid when I bought it.
Oh, so you're supporting...
Yeah.
Don't they get less of a cut?
I don't even know if they got a cut.
Yeah, I don't think they get, do you?
You know what's funny?
Those skins...
Those banners came out while we were playing ALGS so we couldn't buy them.
We couldn't get them.
We couldn't get our own banners.
We literally didn't buy them.
Because it wasn't on...
It also wasn't on their accounts because they had LAN.
Yeah, because with LAN you could play...
Oh, were you in more?
Alright.
You play on like special...
special accounts.
You don't play on your own accounts.
You play on like EA provided accounts with all the skins enabled and shit.
Yeah.
That's basically it.
I agree.
I wanted to buy like at least some of them but I couldn't when I got back home it was gone.
Wait, really?
It was that short?
It was that...
It ended that fast?
I thought it lasted longer.
Didn't they bring it back?
I thought they brought it back for a bit.
No, because I would have bought it.
Yeah.
I can't...
I'm mad.
I'm still mad about that one.
Damn.
It's alright.
You gotta look at my screenshot, Doki.
Whoa.
What screenshot?
Your bald.
Oh, you are.
You don't have your...
You don't have hair.
It's crazy that you guys have to photoshop that shit.
It's not photoshopping.
It's in-game.
Okay, why does he take the helmet off when you're on your POV but on my POV he's just standing here like some fucking... He's embarrassed.
He's on my POV he's just standing like some kind of Avenger.
Like with his arms on his hips like...
And he'll be able to take your helmet off.
Uncle without his helmet.
It's a choice.
Alright, this is my LG It's almost 3 in the morning, guys.
Yeah.
I can feel about it.
This is my LG.
Alright, we gotta win this one.
We gotta win another one.
Two in a row.
See, when we're serious we can win games.
It's so hard to be serious in rank, you know?
It's so hard to be serious in rank.
It's not.
How do you get serious in rank?
You know, that's annoying.
We don't even better.
That means like when we're not serious we're winning.
We just lock in in the last two squads.
That's all.
We just lock in when there's last two.
Like tourneys and like costumes, you never like get to be serious in rank.
It's so hard.
That's so true.
Oh look, that's you.
Look, see Rusty has top fragger cause he locked in.
After we like...
My serious in rank is probably... Alright, I'll be serious.
And that's like everyone and ending.
Except when he gets flanked by a robot.
That's really the point.
It's so scary.
It's horrible.
I think the worst one right now on footsteps is Ashe.
He has no footsteps at all.
That's fucked.
Why are we playing Ashe?
That's crazy cause like on the...
Like before, like Ashe has the biggest footsteps.
Yeah, before she was like clink, clink, clink.
Yeah.
I remember that too.
And now you don't hear the clinks.
Non-existent.
I heard something like somebody behind me.
Oh no, not behind me.
Like literally in front of me.
Oh my god.
He's one, he's one.
That's the front behind.
There's also more there.
I know and I'm fucking dead.
I know like one of them was low.
Literally one HP right now.
One's on Rusty.
One's on this door.
One's on that door.
Okay.
I almost got him.
Nice.
I believe.
I'm so safe.
On the roof, Horizon.
Horizon's on the roof.
There's no way they drop down just to kill you.
There's no way.
Horizon cracked.
I'm fucked.
Okay, I need to heal.
I'm healing.
I'm gonna pop a Phoenix, Rusty.
Yeah, Rusty.
You got this.
Lock in.
He got one.
He got one though.
There's only one left.
Only Poppin left.
Yeah.
Rusty, no.
I don't have shields but I'm heading over.
No!
I finished one.
I got...
I got his banner.
I'm heading up.
I'm pushing up.
He swapped.
He's dead.
Yay!
Okay, I need to swap my gun.
Don't worry, Rusty.
I'm gonna res you.
I need to get a med kit.
Oops.
Sorry.
I need to pick up my stuff.
I got a med kit.
I remember when RPR promised you to play Imperial Howl.
Did that happen, Evan?
Howl didn't wanna do it.
Don't fuck with me.
Damn!
RPR is like, Where the fuck did that come from?
I'm not gonna lie.
Do you want to hear the full story?
Hal said yes to it.
And then when he actually came to doing it, he never wanted to do it.
So I was just like, what am I supposed to do here?
Expose him!
He was just like, I was always either too busy or wouldn't respond to DMs or this and that.
I was just like, well, I tried my best to ask him like 16 times.
That's okay.
Usually when I fucking schedule shit, you know, it goes through.
But that one just didn't want to go through.
It wasn't destined.
That's okay.
In the end, I eventually played with him.
But I don't want people to sit here and be like, oh, you didn't even drive.
You lied.
Like nah, motherfucker.
I fucking tried.
And I communicated.
With you the entire time.
Yeah.
Yeah, he did.
Oh, what a nice guy, RPR.
Yeah.
So late to know.
You were a nice guy all the time.
Well, um...
I won't say that, but...
I can't win.
Like, what's the point of even talking when I can win?
Give me a shotgun.
I have...
No, why don't you give me a Mosam?
Like ping me any shotgun.
If you find a Mosam, I'll give you my Mosam.
I want anything.
I'll take PK, I'll take EVA, I'll take Master, just any shotgun.
We'll ping you one.
Yeah.
Good guy.
Yeah, because you're such a good guy.
I fucking hate you guys.
What did we say?
What do you mean?
See?
We literally pinged you a shotgun.
Yeah.
The last thing a person wants is backhanded compliments.
That's not backhanded.
We were literally complimenting you and you just can't take a compliment.
It's like talking to a wall.
If you're going to say words, at least believe in them yourself.
I do believe in them.
It was so sincere.
Yeah.
My ass.
Any shotgun ammo?
I'm going to get this bat.
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
As a team player, I'm literally right behind you and then we'll aim together.
How many do you need?
I'm good now.
I got 10.
Oh, shit.
That's not inting.
That was...
Damn, Chris.
Damn, poor Chris.
This is crazy.
Wait.
What is this silver player doing in our lobby?
Oh, wait.
His teammate is in here.
Oh, shit.
That's...
Whoa.
Whoever that is, that motherfucker is just...
You said...
He's crying.
He's ready.
Yeah.
I'm coming in.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
You like throw.
You fucking jumped in and booped the guy I was trying to kill.
That scared the shit out of me.
Listen, I was getting on rest here because I thought rest was something so hard.
Oh, come on.
What?
You heard something?
No.
There's a face kit for you.
Golden Akeem buzzin is mad.
Yeah, that Golden Akeem buzzin got yoinked so fast.
How did you lose to someone with a 250 thing?
Says the guy that might lose.
I have a redeploy.
I want to use that.
I need a med kit.
I have no med kits.
Here, I have a med kit.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm going to go this way.
Guys, I'm going to be safe.
Are they rushing in?
No, they're not.
I have no idea what they're doing.
They're literally waiting outside of zone for us.
Then we can kill them.
Yeah.
I'm heading over.
I'm getting so many med kits.
I have redeploy.
Do we want that?
I have five med kits.
I can be here forever.
I need energy ammo.
Someone in my chat said, just want you to know that she ran by six shotguns and didn't ping a single one.
Team player, right?
I don't need to ping any because Restia was pinging them, and I believe that you saw Restia's...
Oh, so that's how it works.
I know you saw Restia's ping.
So why would I ping you more shotgun?
You only need one.
You're right, you're right.
You don't need to do shit for the team.
You're right.
I stopped thinking.
It's not that I don't need to do shit.
I know my team has already done stuff.
Oh, you're right.
Thank you for agreeing.
That's one, by the way.
Oh, never mind.
Yeah, yeah.
Where did that Venture go?
Wait, he's one.
There we go.
There's a Horizon that was one here.
At least I think she was a Horizon.
Oh, hey, you have a gold ratio.
There's a gold ratio for you.
That's sick.
How long did you have that one?
Oh, look, it's not even on my body.
It's literally a guy that just died that I killed.
Yeah, yeah, but look.
How long did you have that one?
Nothing to say about that.
How long was it there?
Literally just killed him.
I saw him using it to block my shots.
I was like, whoa, that's something that my teammate, who is Newcastle, would definitely want.
Because I'm a team player.
So if I check your VOD, that would be...
Yeah, no, check it.
Watch my VOD.
Give me that plus one view.
I encourage you to watch it.
No, no, I'll watch it after the stream is over.
You know what?
I'm going to fucking get the Zombo.
This guy ran away with one HP.
I don't know where he went though.
Is there a sniper stock anywhere?
Hold on.
This one.
You all just killed us.
Sad face.
My bad.
What did we kill?
You don't even feel sorry for them.
You don't even feel sorry for him.
That's so fucked up.
Well, you killed him, not me.
Oh wait, I killed him?
I don't feel sorry.
Yeah, I like the honesty.
I mean, it's not like I would feel sorry.
It's better than like a fake I'm sorry.
Yeah, exactly.
I just want him to know that I'm real.
I'm the realest.
Yeah, I mean, you know, formalities and shit.
I said sorry.
I don't have to mean it.
Whoa.
Yes, you do.
And you're a faker.
No, I don't.
You're a fucking faker.
I'm literally a faker of this game.
You're a faker of this game.
You'd have more than one championship win.
I am a faker.
Okay.
So would you say Imperial Holly is a faker of the game or Zero is a faker of this game?
Here we go.
Start some drama.
Tell me none of them because Faker will rage.
Yeah, neither.
Faker literally would not rage.
That's so true.
He's too chill for that.
I feel like he's not though.
He cares about the game but he's not a nice guy.
He doesn't yell at his teammates like they do.
Okay, there's a Kraber.
Whoa!
No one does that to his teammates.
So none of them...
Wait, there's two Rizzes.
Are we going for the first Rizz?
No.
There's people fighting on this side of the wall.
Yeah, I heard it.
Yeah, me too.
Wait, what the fuck?
I got shot from behind.
Yeah.
I'm in gas.
I need a bat.
Where is this gas coming from?
Behind you, literally.
Ash is cracked.
Ash is low.
Where is he?
Behind the bins.
Behind the mythic bin.
Oh, nice.
That's fucking right.
That's for flanking us.
Where did the other guy go?
Probably under.
Right here, right here, right here.
Oh, alright.
Lifeline.
Behind this rock?
Alright.
Hello, lifeline.
Lifeline?
Above you.
Knocked one.
Alright, batting.
I'm batting.
Flying above.
Make sure you're dead, dead.
Oh, he has gold.
Nice.
That guy is cracked.
Oh, shit.
How many?
Two, two, two.
I got one.
I'm not.
I'm spotting.
He's flashed, though.
I'm batting.
He has hammerpoint, he has hammerpoint.
It's okay.
I have gold rest.
Who cares about him?
I'm just fucking stopping the lifeline rest.
That's why I'm the team player.
Dude, there is a lifeline is happening.
I'm coming from this angle.
From this angle.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Yeah, he is.
Oh, my God.
There's so much.
Horizon, horizon, horizon.
Oh, my God.
There's two.
Look at this guy.
Look at this idiot.
I'm going to go res if I can.
Cover.
Smoke us, maybe.
No, no, maybe.
Smoke, smoke, smoke.
Just smoke.
Oh, my God.
There's a fucking...
There's a... God, stay calm.
Smoke again right here, doc, and res.
I don't have smoke.
Okay, now I do.
Okay, big.
Look, I'm even healing.
I'm even healing in my smoke because you taught me that.
Yup.
There's someone on us.
Someone is on us.
On the wall, on the wall, on the wall.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
One's flash, one's flash.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm stuck on a...
Dude, this game is so bugged.
Last guy, last guy.
He's super far.
Super far.
He's just watching.
He's going up.
Oh, you don't have gold res.
Oh, my...
I got three res.
I got the bug where you reload your Mozams and then you shoot one bullet and then it reloads them again, bro.
Oh, my god.
We gotta do another.
Alright, I'll do... This is the LG.
Alright, redemption arc for RPI.
That's so annoying.
The collab.
We got collab.
There's another Kraber.
Yeah, because mythic bins.
God damn.
Wait, I think he's dead.
Unless...
Oh...
You got another collab?
Woah.
Oh.
Wait, he can res himself?
No, he's dead.
I can't believe I got that shit...
The fucking stupid Mozam.
Someone which has like, what was the bug that made him not res?
No, but...
Okay, why would I res you there when I can kill their lifeline that's going for a res?
Yeah, but if you trusted res you could have got it.
If it's a...
No, I was full.
Yeah, he was full.
Yeah, he was.
Then why weren't you resing then?
I don't have a go-knock.
He didn't have a go-knock.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah, but you are next to her.
You are next to her and I'm not.
I'm not going to turn around and go back and res you.
You turned next to her.
Okay.
What do you mean?
RPR's chat.
You should reset first and kill the guy.
That moment where he was next to us.
RPR's chat.
We both saw you next to me.
Why would I res?
Yeah.
There was no cover behind me.
You literally walked away in front of our eyes twice.
Once to Resdia and once to me.
He muted.
He knows he lost.
He knows he lost the argument.
Yeah, he knows he lost.
The throw of the century.
I can't believe it, Resdia.
And then he blamed us.
Why don't you res?
I can't believe it.
Alright, don't worry.
He's probably muting and talking to his chat now.
I can't believe Resdia and Doki would blame me.
I won the EU Championship in LAN.
Everything I say is correct.
Alright.
I believe in us.
We got this.
We're gamers.
Remember chat?
He's not mad.
He's just European.
That's so racist.
No, it's not.
Is he gay or European?
I actually don't know this song.
You don't know that?
That's from... was it Legally Blonde?
That's from Legally Blonde.
I love that song.
Is he gay or European?
Alright, you guys done fucking yapping?
Is he mad or European?
Not seeing you guys' voices.
Oh my god, did you miss our voices that much to come back?
I can mute again.
Stay muted.
I'm really fine with that.
Alright.
Ooh, Wingman.
I'm not gonna hit anything.
What else am I supposed to do when dumb and fucking dumber are arguing when muted?
Wait, who's dumber?
Both of you.
Alright.
I wanna see how many shots I'm gonna miss on Wingman.
I'm not gonna contribute.
I have a Wingman.
Oh, I hit one!
I'm gonna charge my shield.
I'm doing my roof.
I'm healing.
Wait, his teammates are all here.
Flesh on Lifeline?
Yes.
That's how it works.
Team game.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I never had the experience to be fair.
Nice.
One of them is cracked.
Yeah, we did it!
I'll play Wingman the entire game.
Wait, we should all play Wingman.
No.
Wait, why not?
Why not?
I have my Wingman.
I have a Wingman.
You should stick to spray weapons.
Yep, I hit all my shots today.
How many shots did you shoot?
I hit five!
Five!
Five out of five!
Literally five out of five!
If you hit all your shots, why didn't you knock one?
I got them.
I cracked them.
Five shots on Wingman.
Because I hit five shots on three different people.
And that's why they were all low.
I hit five shots on three different people and it cracked all three.
That's how math works.
That's what you do, yeah.
That's what you did.
Oh my god.
You sort of deserve that.
I just got routed by... there's nowhere.
Misty, are you okay?
I knew that I would run here.
That's the Dragoon.
He's here.
He's very specific.
That's the Dragoon here to defend me.
I saw it happen in my life.
He's here to defend me.
Thank you.
He knew I was right.
Okay, we should craft him.
Where's the nearest crafter?
Like all the way...
Turbine?
Okay, I'll take the...
Alright, I'm redeploying the Turbine.
How does it feel up here that you're going to be saved by me?
You're not going to save me.
If you res me, I'll jump over the map.
Oh my god.
What a team player.
I'll wait here.
Okay, so I'll craft and...
What if I craft and rest you at res?
Would you still jump off?
You'd jump off halfway.
No, you should just not wear armor.
You might as well be half dead.
I crafted the wrong thing.
As in your life.
I told you not to res me.
He wants someone that res'd you, not me.
Res me!
There's a team fight over here.
What did res'd you do to you?
He did nothing to you.
No, he definitely did nothing to me.
You're going to fight this, res'd you?
He's on your side by automatic default.
He's my enemy.
Whoa!
He's a neutral party.
Yeah, he has no bias.
It's like he's a judge.
Dude, not a balance at all.
Yes, he is.
Wait, to our right.
There's people behind me.
Flesh?
Oh my god.
You know when your teammates get shot by a different team, then you turn it on and you help them.
Then don't get shot by a different team.
I didn't res myself there.
Yeah, but now I have a different team on me.
Yeah, that's a great res.
It's my favorite res.
When my teammates res me and then they run away from me.
Now you're getting three men sent from this side.
Three people from this direction.
No, I got grappled!
I got grappled!
Alright, we gotta play another then.
You're right.
Why?
Oh my god.
Because RPI embarrassed himself on stream.
We gotta redeem him.
But can you guys at least res me and then stick with me instead of leave me alone to get chased by a different team?
That's not our fault you got chased.
Then don't res me!
Don't res me then!
I'd rather not be resed.
Then don't die!
Literally land in a safer spot.
I res and I look around.
Yeah, there's nobody there.
I hate this team.
Don't you don't.
If you hate this team, you would have left.
But you're still here.
Yeah, because I have shit to do.
I need a waiting room.
I need time to rest.
You need a waiting room?
Yeah, I got something in three hours I have to do on stream so I have to waste time.
But what are you doing in three hours?
You wouldn't understand if I hadn't told you.
What are you doing in three hours?
No, tell us.
My Discord has a tournament.
Oh shit, an Apex tournament?
Your Discord?
Wait, are they good?
Why don't you invite me?
No.
Why would I invite you to my viewers Discord tournament?
Yeah, why don't you invite us?
Why would you guys play my viewers tournament?
We could play as a team together.
And see if they can beat us.
No, I have to spectate them.
I'm not going to play against them.
Well, if they land on you just to kill you, then you can spectate.
True.
I'm supposed to cast the tournament, not kill them all.
Well, I love your viewers.
So you're trying to say...
I bet you a viewer in there is better than you.
She hasn't seen my viewers.
Wow!
You're scared.
You're scared of your viewers.
You're scared of losing to them.
I'm so scared of them.
Yeah, you're scared of losing to your viewers.
Yeah, you're right.
I'm so fucking scared.
If you're not scared, you would do a 1v1 tournament against your viewers.
You just want to play against viewers and stomp them so you feel better about yourself.
No, I just want you to do a 1v1 tournament against your viewers to see it.
We already have a 1v1 tournament.
But I never play against your viewers.
It's not fair.
What do you mean?
So you don't think they have a chance to beat you.
Of course they don't.
Are you crazy, Howard?
A bunch of plot players are going to beat me in competitive.
I have like, pred players that watch me.
Are you trying to say you don't have pred players that watch you?
Not your viewers.
They're my viewers.
No, you don't know about plot players, RPR.
They think they're the best.
Yeah, I mean, Rusty has plat.
Yeah, Rusty has plat.
He can literally beat you up.
Okay, but Rusty has plat because he doesn't play the game.
Yes, he does.
How did he get to plat?
If I look at his YouTube channel right now, it's like literally Apex.
It's like the majority of his YouTube channel is literally like Apex.
What do you mean?
Can I ask you, can you annoy fucking Rusty and not me?
For once.
What do you mean?
Oh my god, he threw everything at us.
No, no ammo.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
What the fuck, another team?
Oh my god, he's won.
Oh, goodbye, RPR.
You're so fucked.
Are you still alive?
How are you guys dead?
What do you mean?
We landed.
We were landing.
200 ping.
How the fuck am I gonna get a gun?
I have 250 and I did five times your damage.
Who let you beat Joe Vassi?
I don't have a gun.
Yeah, Rusty had no gun.
Keep giving me jump master.
We're gonna keep going right there.
We're gonna go right there.
Again and again and again.
Keep giving it to me.
Fine, we will.
Alright.
It's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, I'm not scared.
I'm not scared either, which is why I jumped here.
I'm not fucking scared.
I am not scared either, which is why I landed there.
Specifically.
I literally was a Horizon.
I can't pick up a gun.
Why are you playing Horizon on 200 ping though?
Horizon is good for 200 ping.
No!
When you press Q, you just lag mid-air.
Yeah, but then...
That's 250.
200 is fine.
Yeah.
This guy is on crack.
And if he's lagging in the air, that means it's harder to hit him for the other teammates.
True.
Yeah, see, if he can't hit anybody...
I can show you guys...
I can show you guys the clip of my viewer's skill level.
Damn.
Live on stream?
You have to show it on your own stream too.
Yeah, I mean...
We've been watching that clip for a while now.
It happened on stream.
Chat, someone give it to me.
Chat, I bet you...
This is one of the...
This clip is one of the higher ranked players.
Wait, how high is...
How high the rank is?
Like a diamond.
But like...
Which season?
Listen...
I bet my viewers can...
Can win against your viewers.
By process of elimination...
You have more viewers.
Numbers beat numbers.
What do you mean?
That's not true.
The average is out.
But even their average is higher than your average.
No.
Yes, it is.
You're literally an Apex streamer.
You should have more Apex viewers then.
Shouldn't you?
You're an Apex streamer too.
What do you mean?
The last Apex stream I did was like 2-3 weeks ago.
You came from Apex.
That's not so long ago.
I thought it was gonna be like 3 months ago.
Yeah, I know.
Maybe it was.
I don't remember.
What was like last Apex?
There you go.
In general, I got the perfect clip.
Well, we're landing.
Oh hey!
Rusty has Jumpmaster.
So we're gonna live.
True.
It's like dumb and dumber bro in that clip.
Wait,
is there anyone that landed with us?
Oh yeah, there is.
Yeah, two teams and I'm getting sent.
I need help.
We're heading over.
We're literally walking as fast as we could.
Well, I cracked three of them, but there's just three of them on me.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Okay, Restia, I'm heading over.
Live.
What's embarrassing is that I'm probably still going to do more damage than you.
I'll show you that here.
What?
All right.
Yay!
Wow, good job, guys.
We did it!
Where's my vault?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Wait, I want to grab my vault.
Oh, you only had a double sentinel.
That's fucked.
Wait, I want to run a sentinel.
Wait, I want to run a longbow.
Oh, nice.
All right, my turn to snipe.
Mom said it's my turn to snipe.
Holy shit, 300 ping.
How did you get to 300 ping?
I thought you had VPN on.
There's people shooting to my left.
Because Apex servers are perfect, and they never lag.
What do you mean?
Oh my god, there's no sentinel.
Yeah, I only found the longbow.
There's a sentinel I dropped in here.
Yeah, oh yeah, he has two sentinels.
Yeah, look at his box.
I only had one sentinel.
Really?
I saw you had two.
Unless they swapped with you.
For some reason.
No, I had one.
Oh, wait, I shouldn't have done that.
Where are we going, guys?
To the basement.
RGL, where do we go?
Wait, there are?
Oh, I see him.
He's running.
Nice, I also hit a shot too.
So it should be like, almost dead.
Where is he?
Oh, he grappled behind.
Oh, what the fuck?
What are you doing here?
He's dead.
Hello.
Oh my god, toxic, toxic.
You're so stupid.
Yeah, he's dead, we did it.
You alright?
Yeah, they're fine.
Where are they?
RGL, where are they?
They're like, far.
What do you want from me?
Do you not have eyes or ears?
My eyes don't work as well as yours.
Because you're a more professional gamer.
How?
Yeah, I wear glasses.
Into your Chinese mode.
It requires for other people to be nice, so I can be nice to them.
You guys are not nice.
I'm nice.
Wait, I can't reach that.
I can't reach that zip.
Go from the bottom.
Wait, the last guy is with me.
Wait, what the fuck?
Rave is so bad now, you can see where he is.
Just stepped on this motherfucker.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he's over here.
No, one's right here.
How?
He's Loba.
Guys, I missed.
Oh, I hit my shots.
He's one.
He's literally one.
He's got a Loba again.
Bro, he keeps doing these weak jumpings.
Okay.
He's hiding in the corner.
Oh my god.
Please.
Stop running.
You're just gonna die.
She's gonna run into a different team and die.
That's true.
Didn't that team rez over there in front of us?
Yep.
Still alive.
Wait, where did she go?
You're never gonna catch her.
She's gone.
She disappeared.
She probably braceleted again.
Oh, shots here.
Wait.
Oh, on me.
He fucking domed in me.
We killed this motherfucker.
Yeah, kill him.
He's phoenixing.
What did he...
Oh.
Wait, where...
Where's his teammate?
He shot from above.
Alright, he was great in the video game.
On me?
He's finishing me.
Just fucking kill the guy.
Oh, we're looking at this.
Can you thirst him for me?
Cue me up.
10 seconds.
What the fuck?
Where's an Ashe?
I'm a team player.
On top of... on here?
Where?
Oh, he is here.
79?
I'm missing?
Because of the... because of the zone?
That's why?
Yeah, his teammates are...
His teammates are in front of me.
Oh, I hit that though.
I need to heal.
You guys don't understand the knockback.
The knockback hurts guys.
You know what's annoying?
Is that you use... you can use a heat shield in zone and you still fucking aim punch while heat shielding in zone.
Wait, really?
I didn't know that.
That's fucking bad.
That's fucking weird.
Alright.
I have to heal.
The Magi we just killed.
I'm running.
I'm running as fast as I can.
You got a med kit?
I do.
Here.
Thank you.
Maybe they know we are heading over.
No, because there is a fight in front of us.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm syringing.
I'm doing my job.
Horizon?
Wait, did we thirst that?
Fucking tractor?
Yeah, we did.
Okay.
A guy with me no audio again, bro.
This is insane.
I got him.
I'm rezzing.
Fucking hate this game.
Wait, I...
It's Ash with no fucking audio again, dude.
I heard him.
That's why I stopped the rezz.
What do you mean?
I heard him.
I had the ears.
Why does Horizon have no fucking audio?
Yeah, I did.
That guy just was next to me.
I was like, huh?
What the fuck was that?
I don't know.
But that wasn't Metal Legs.
He doesn't have Metal Legs.
Yeah, but there is an overall inability to hear footsteps in this game.
That is not related to Metal Legs.
I need like...
I have zero attachments on my vault.
I didn't even notice that.
A 2x.
I'm going to zone from here.
I see people here.
From where?
There, okay.
I'm here, panning over.
We gotta walk over.
Well, Brescia is taking the zip.
I'm walking.
Good idea.
Crack the pathfinder.
Was it a good idea for us to walk to them?
I don't have an angle.
One of them is blue armor.
Smoke them.
I want to shoot them.
Yeah, but they're going to do more damage to us than we will to them.
Oh, you're right.
There's a squad right here.
Brescia, stop focusing on them.
Focus on the guys that are ganking us.
I didn't focus on them.
I'm coming.
He's one.
He's literally one.
What?
How did I lose that much HP?
I need your knockdown.
I'm pushing.
I'm putting it up.
I'm reloading.
I believe in Brescia.
I believed in him.
I knew it.
I'm just going to rez.
Why are you on the other side of the shield?
I don't fucking know.
Even I want to know why I'm over here too.
I was wondering too.
What is our raid portal?
Oh, he's portaling them.
We should push the portal before the other team comes.
They're dead.
Now look at the other team.
I'm ulting, so they'll have to run into my house.
Two of us with portal.
I'm medkidding.
They have to run through my ult too.
They're going back for some reason.
They're taking it.
They are?
Left side, Maggy.
Maggy, 45, blue.
One in the zone in front of me.
What the fuck are all these?
I'm getting hit by everything.
I'm coming over.
I'm healing.
Nice.
I don't know where the last guy is.
I need the blue shields.
I can't finish her in what?
Where are they?
Oh, in front of us.
What?
No, that's a different team.
That's a different team.
I am...
I need a heal.
Oh, guy.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm going to take this.
I'm going to open this bin right now.
And get a heal too in this.
Yay.
What's in it?
Oh, hey.
There's a glow of dawn buff.
It's an R9.
Hold the wingman.
What's the point?
Do I not have to ring this?
You guys have syringes?
Oh, yeah.
I dropped two medkits here as well.
Just pop medkit.
Okay.
I have medkit, but I just...
Oh, hey.
There's a glow helmet.
They're zipping to the left here.
Let's go here.
Okay.
I have the medkit.
Here I am.
I'm heading over.
They're fighting or some shit in front of me.
Whoa.
In front of me.
Fighting like crazy.
Yeah.
I saw the stray shots that...
Go from the left side so we're in zone.
Wait.
I wanna poke them though.
Really?
I'mma poke them.
Knocked one.
Don't commit to that side.
Oh my god.
He's so low.
The Pathfinder's one.
In a corner cracked.
One's below here.
Yeah, yeah.
But he has to be in zone.
He's lifeline raising.
I got him.
Pathfinder's heading to you.
Pathfinder one dead.
Yay!
Alright.
He's literally in this corner.
I believe in you, Rustia.
Whoa.
That guy's living for so long.
Yay!
Holy shit.
He lived for so long in that corner.
He was behind.
I was gonna say.
Why did that take a while?
That's crazy.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
I'm fighting.
It's a bad fight.
We can, right?
I think so.
Yeah.
Wait, wait.
I can't.
I'm healing.
I'm coming now.
There's heat shields around us, by the way.
We might die because of this.
No, no.
You won't die.
You're down.
Nope.
I need a med kit.
I need it here too.
I dropped one.
I'm med-kitting right now.
I didn't get a chance to grab another Mose down.
How does he see me?
How the fuck did he see me then?
Um, how do we get across?
We need to kill these guys.
We have an option.
Just go with my...
Oh.
Wait, come with me here.
We can take the zip.
Okay.
We gotta go down here.
They all shot me though.
I need a bat.
Rest here.
We're here already.
Yeah, I know.
Get ahead of this idiots.
Team over here.
Team in front of us.
I'm going here.
I'm getting ahead of them.
I'm getting ahead of all of this shit.
I smoked it.
I have ult too.
Can they fuck off with the fucking snipers, man?
I need like another Mose down.
Oh hey, nice med-kit.
That's what I needed.
No!
That guy with the bow needs to die.
Yeah, I'm fucking med-kitting.
I'm batting right now.
He's 1 HP.
He's literally 1.
Where?
I got a Phoenix.
I have no long range by the way.
He's over there.
What the hell?
Where's the other team?
Right side somewhere.
This guy is getting a left angle on us.
We should just fucking... I ult.
We should just push him.
Go there, Doki.
Go there.
Ult him.
I'm ulting it.
They're all there.
There's two of them now.
Yeah, I ulted.
The other team pushed them so we don't push now.
The other team took their height.
Yeah, but I can... I'm going to go from here.
This side.
40?
Flash?
Pathfinder's flashed.
He's down.
He's knocked.
He's not pushing up.
Why am I getting...
One team dead.
I'm going to ult on Doki.
Okay.
I got stunned.
I couldn't ult on you.
I'm right here.
Wait on me.
Oh shit.
They're hard.
Yeah, yeah.
You're fine.
Yeah, I'm batting.
They're pushing.
They're pushing hard.
Yeah.
I'm looking for you.
I'm batting.
I almost cracked another.
What's my ult?
Ult him?
Wait on me.
On me.
This side.
Bang one.
Dead.
Stop.
I got the other.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Yeah, let's go.
I did nothing.
Look at us go.
You were serious though, weren't you?
Yeah, we were serious.
Look at us locked in.
He was serious though, so it's all that matters.
Yeah.
See, we're such a good team when we focus.
It's almost like we're good when you're just not fucking yapping and complaining all the time.
Yeah.
Look at us.
Holy shit.
What?
Someone just gifted 10 and Twitch gifted 18.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
What a good LG.
Look at that.
See?
What the fuck is that?
You won the lottery.
Fucking gotcha.
I freaking love gotcha, dude.
Alright.
GG's guys.
That was fun.
Are you done?
Yeah, I'm done.
Ristia, are you done too?
I can play.
I gotta go.
It's been four hours, guys.
It's almost 4 in the morning.
No, it's like 3.30 a.m.
right now.
Fuck, I don't know.
GG's, guys.
That was fun.
I'm playing with you again, Ristia.
Yeah.
Definitely done.
Yeah, yeah.
Gotta do this again.
GG's, everybody.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat.
GG's, good luck with the rest of Diamond Games.
Good luck, Ristia.
He's gonna be in my team.
You gotta say good luck to me too.
Otherwise, you're gonna lose.
No, that's fine.
Anyway, good luck to you, Ristia.
I believe in you.
Alright, bye, RPR.
That was fun, though.
I had a great time, chat.
It was great playing some Apex again.
We're almost gold.
We're almost...
We're almost gold, guys.
I mean, that's pretty good.
And I locked in.
We locked in in the last game.
It was great playing with Ristia again.
It's been a while.
Not even seven plus months.
It's been eight plus months since the last time we played with Ristia.
So I'm glad, like, you know, I reached out to Ristia to play this week.
And then we were like, let's play with RPR too.
And it's been fun.
I had a great time with both of them.
And it's nice to shoot my gun again.
Guys, see?
I'm not that washed.
I told you guys.
When I lock in, I'm not that washed.
I still hit some shots.
I still got it.
Soon I'll be a gold player again.
Anyway, guys.
I had a great time playing.
Tomorrow we are...
By the way, I said no to the deadlock.
I haven't said no yet.
I haven't said no yet to the deadlock.
But I'm going to DM them and be like, I can't do it.
Because Surefour was like, yeah, maybe not.
And I was like, alright, I'm not doing it.
Because I was like, I don't fucking know what I'm doing.
So I'm going to DM them and be like, yeah, I'm going to say no to the invite.
I told you guys.
It heavily depended on if Surefour joins my team or not.
And he was like, yeah, maybe not.
So I'm not going to join that.
I'm not going to join that deadlock tournament.
Anyway.
Tomorrow we're going to learn deadlock tomorrow.
I have no idea.
I have no idea how it's going to go.
Because I think I touched deadlock like three times ever since I got into the beta test in April.
I've been in it since April.
And I've touched the game three times.
So tomorrow will be the fourth time I try deadlock.
So we'll see.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I was like, hanging out with the homies playing Apex.
And I hope you guys had a great time watching too.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Sorry we didn't have a long chat.
I'm trying not to overuse my voice this week because we did a lot of streams so far for this week.
And it was like in super long hours.
We've been doing like three plus hour streams the past week.
So this for this week.
So I'm trying not to overuse my voice.
So I'm really sorry that we haven't had some after stream chats in a bit.
But like the moment everything cools down we will bring them back.
Anyway guys, bye bye everybody.
Bye.